ça va très bien salut à tous on est
reparti pour un nouvel événement sauf
avec grand plaisir yes le tata style
aujourd'hui donc on a deux tournois on a
le on a le master avec Carlsen Caravana
et tout tous les top niveau et on a le
challenger aussi qui se qualifie pour le
Master avec plein de jeunes talents
des gros poids lourds et des pépites
c'est ça alors du coup dans le dans le
toit master on va vous présenter un
petit peu un petit peu les joueurs alors
je vais vous montrer un petit peu ici ce
que j'ai
on a donc on a Carlson Kawana Guiri
dingly Rennes on a Richard rapport
wesleo à rognan ça c'est un petit peu on
va dire les 7 joueurs
on va dire les 7
7 des meilleurs joueurs du monde qui
sont habitués aux retournant Kevin ouais
les presque papa maintenant quand on
voit le reste du tableau quoi
effectivement mais c'est effectivement
des habitués depuis une décennie on va
dire pour pour la plupart
voir un petit peu plus pour les von
harrognan
et du coup je suis hyper intéressant de
voir derrière tous les goûts cache
erégasis un peu plus grand mais tu vois
aussi amuse auto Rohff qui est mort par
exemple
forest qui est qui est un très très bon
joueur joueur local qui d'ailleurs a
gagné l'édition l'année dernière mais tu
vois en fait tous ces jeunes les trois
indiens
abusotarov moi ça me fait vachement
rêver tu vois tu vois gamer qui a fait
vice champion du monde de Blitz
on voit à bouttrov qui est ancien
champion du monde de partir rapide c'est
de genre qui ont 18 ans appelle
et donc ça va être intéressant de voir
la moitié du plateau qui est bon on va
dire déjà qui m'ont beaucoup
d'expérience dans dans la scène
internationale comme même 45 % du monde
et cette autre joueur qui sont un peu
nouveau et qui sont bien sûr déjà tous
très très fort ils sont tous quasiment
2700 Elo ce qui est stratosphérique
complètement et bon Maxou de l'eau il
devait pas être là normalement c'était
Yann Christophe Douda qu'on connaît
mieux stouf qui est vraiment lui aussi
un des gros habitués le joueur polonais
il a été remplacé pour raison perso on
sait pas trop enfin en tout cas je ne
sais pas mais toujours est-il que
maintenant c'est c'est ma xbox loup qui
est présent et pareil la tête de série
numéro 1
Salem Salah qui n'est pas là dans le
challenger et qui a été remplacé par un
joueur serbe si je dis pas de bêtises
ivitch un grand maître à presque 2600
mais en tout cas oui c'est c'est
[Musique]
que Caravana a gagné
quatre fois
non pardon excuse-moi quatre scène 8
fois à rognon 4 fois qu'il a gagné car
wanna qui a gagné deux fois
qui est assez drôle c'est que anus a
fait 5 x 2e ah oui oui et donc donc ok
bon c'est un genre local qui qui est
bien sûr dans le top 10 depuis
maintenant une décennie et
il a jamais réussi à gagner l'événement
je pense ça lui tient à cœur il veut
peut-être le gagner cette année on va
voir en tout cas ce qui nous fait
deuxième ça commence à faire un petit
peu rageant et mais là franchement ça va
être intéressant et je pense aussi avec
nos petits Paris tu sais qu'à chaque
fois qu'on a des petits Paris qui
viennent j'imagine que ta peau j'ai pas
travaillé j'ai pas travaillé j'imagine
que tu as bien travaillé toi non non je
ne travaille pas tu sais je ne travaille
pas avant hein je vais tout en même
temps je suis vraiment un mec rigolo
du coup mais là ça va être intéressant
de voir vraiment est-ce que vraiment la
Genèse va réussir à renverser
vraiment dans l'expérience
la jeunesse est très impressionnante
autant ok en cadence lente ça reste des
super joueurs à 2700 mais les gros
cracks me semblent assez un des
boulonnable à cette cadence de jeu vu
l'expérience après ce n'est que mon avis
on va voir en tout cas parce que c'est
hyper intéressant en vrai
il y a des joueurs qui ont eu
dernièrement des des
tu vois des petits moments un petit peu
de la vide comme on voit aronium qui a
perdu beaucoup de points et l'eau qui
aux Olympiades qui est qui a été qui a
pas très très bien joué tu vois on a
aussi karwana qui est sur une pente un
peu descendante
on a aussi rapport qui dernièrement on
n'a pas non plus vraiment briller
tu vois parmi les anciens et
chez les nouveaux terriasis qui tous les
jours surprend la planète on a aussi on
a aussi goûte
[Musique]
c'est c'est
tous les jeunes en puissance qui monte
qui qui gagne 20 à 30 points à chaque
placement et l'eau
moi
je pense je pense qu'ils sont à leur
paliers un petit peu parce que là on est
en méforme par exemple carbonara il
affiche 27 66 alors qu'arigazi affiche
27 22 maintenant pour gagner les points
qui lui manquent pour arriver parmi les
tout meilleurs mondiaux et Regis
ça va être de les battre et ça ça va
être une autre dimension il a battra à
terme parce qu'il est plus jeune etc en
tout cas il va clairement je pense les
inquiéter à terme mais là on va voir à
mon avis il reste un petit peu tendre
par rapport à l'élite mondiale je parle
vraiment Carlson à rognan carwana ce que
tu as cité même guéri
et du coup on verra aussi dingueren
d'ailleurs et je pense que ça va être un
petit peu un petit peu juste mais
j'espère qu'il me fera mentir c'est
l'aspect théorique qui m'intéresse pour
un joueur comme mérigazie qui a tendance
à jouer des petits débuts surtout donc
en bled sur internet mais non il en a
besoin donc qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
théoriquement contre les monstres du
circuit qui étudie la théorie moderne
depuis des années des années quoi donc
il y a une grosse expérience qui a été
créée Carlson pour ces matchs de
championnats du monde car Wana c'est
pareil à Rouana à rognan pour tous ces
gros tournois je pense que ça va pas
être si évident pour pour eux de tenir
les les darons au niveau au niveau
théorique après on verra le temps pour
eux je pense c'est vraiment un gros
challenge de s'affronter un petit peu au
meilleur joueur du monde comme caracène
Caravana à rognan saut tout ça et je
pense que tu vois là j'ai vu un hier une
petite photo avec Hanan qui était venue
un petit peu en tant
coach peut-être je sais pas
ambassadeurs aussi mais en fait j'ai vu
que bon j'avais aussi fait une interview
de Google sortiascom qui qui avait parlé
des grands entraînement qui faisait avec
avec un an dans
un an que par exemple tous les petits
indiens qui etc avec amende aussi quelle
forme et du coup la photo avec Anna tu
vois je peux intéresser et en fait moi
je pense que tous les joueurs là c'est
vraiment bon ils sont ils sont très
jeunes c'est le futur des échecs et je
pense qu'ils ont vraiment beaucoup à
faire d'entre moi comme ça et beaucoup
beaucoup approuvé aussi et je pense que
ils sont préparés quoi je pense qu'ils
sont prêts
donc en tout cas on va voir ce qui ce
qu'il nous faut on avait eu quand même
après la mandat qui avait joué l'année
dernière l'événement il avait pas été
ridicule du tout hein
toi tu avais parié sur sur vente je m'en
souviens qu'il y avait gagné l'événement
donc du coup bah juste pas chat quoi
j'avais tout perdu mais
mais
par exemple de l'année dernière il avait
déjà brillé dans ce tournoi donc là il a
quand même un an un an d'entraînement et
d'expérience en plus donc en tout cas on
va voir mais cette jeunesse moi c'est
vraiment un tournoi un plateau qui
m'intéresse particulièrement parce que
je trouve que c'est c'est hyper
intéressant de voir les jeunes qui
montrent contre la contre les les
habitudes du circuit cas tout à fait et
puis c'était une volonté d'ailleurs de
l'organisateur du tournoi parce qu'on le
rappelle c'est pas véritablement des
qualifications même s'il y a des joueurs
qui montent du Challenger c'est une
minorité de joueurs
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment sur
invitation et on peut regretter qu'il
n'y ait pas de joueurs français quand
même VL comme fearuja maintenant il y a
un très très beau plateau avec comme tu
le dis la jeunesse montante contre les
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux et quand on
parle de jeunesse montante
s'inscrivent dans une logique de très
très haut niveau puisqu'on a vu Abdou
satorrov gagner les championnats du
monde de deux parties rapides l'an passé
cette année ça a été gagné par Carlsen
comme le Blitz mais en tout cas ils sont
de plus en plus dangereux on a vu
d'ailleurs avant Vincent Kemer qu'on
connaît depuis longtemps puisque quand
il était maître il faisait même des Open
en France maintenant il est grand maître
très fort grand maître et il a été assez
incroyable dans ces derniers
championnats du monde qu'on a eu la
chance de commenter aux fin décembre
stouf on a vu un Vincent Kemer qui
s'approche de l'élim mondiale en cadence
rapide et en cadence Blitz complètement
donc non hyper excitant ce petit ce
petit tournoi donc là on a déjà des
appareils non donc on a 2 forest qui va
jouer
on a rapport contre about torov donc ça
c'est intéressant parce que c'est encore
une fois les deux appareils la jeunesse
entre guillemets contre l'expérience on
a qu'à la guéri donc là deux papas qui
se jouent
on a goûtage qu'elle est blanc contre
Ding donc Ding qui va jouer le match
championnat du monde d'ici quelques mois
contre
est-ce que Ding va sortir les prépas
je ne sais pas
je doute quand même un petit peu je
pense qu'il va jouer vraiment
pour moi Sophie doit enfin il doit un
minimum surprendre enfin il peut pas il
peut pas non jouer son répertoire pour
être hyper ciblé non ça serait très
étonnant on sait que il prépare même des
ouvertures spécifiquement pour cet
événement non je pense qu'il va jouer un
peu au pied levé ce tournoi
en tout cas les ouvertures c'est pas
vraiment là où il va vraiment essayer de
faire la différence parce que le goût se
prépare pour le Championnat du Monde
donc pas dévoiler des secrets quelques
mois avant ça serait ridicule
exact donc on a ensuite en dessous on a
max ODLO contre Kemer donc Mathieu de
l'eau qui qui vient remplacer du coup
exactement donc match hyper intéressant
on a bien sur caracène à rognan encore
une fois ça c'est le derby on a vu déjà
aujourd'hui c'est ça ouais donc ce qu'on
regardera bien sûr en priorité c'est
bien sûr
Carlsen à rognan on regardera tout et
puis le petit Prague irigasi qui aussi
promet parce que bon
voilà même si des joueurs du même pays
et qui sont copains et ben en fait ils
vont se la coller et ça qu'on aime en
fait il y a pas d'arrangement
les deux joueurs ont tout approuvé ils
vont essayer de de
marquer leur premier point et de lancer
un peu l'entendre quoi les joueurs
indiens sont ambitieux en règle générale
après on peut se passer en disant ça et
assister à une petite nul théorique donc
on va pas trop en faire souffre mais
honnêtement
c'est deux joueurs qui aiment bien
bastonner reggae ici on voit il aime
bien tout envoyer ouais non je vois pas
trop trop
[Musique]
pour cela variété je vois pas une petite
nul enfin ça peut être nul mais ça va
être un combat nul de combat exactement
et ils ont vraiment une culture et
d'ailleurs tous les joueurs de haut
niveau jeunes ont cette culture de dire
que le match nul c'est un demi mauvais
résultats plutôt qu'un demi bon résultat
vaut mieux jouer toutes ces parties à
fond pour gagner pour progresser aux
échecs même si on a le confort du match
nul qui existe qui n'est pas le cas dans
tous les sports il faut absolument dans
une démarche de progression je voulais
vraiment à fond pour le gain c'est ça
non mais c'est clair les joueurs les
joueurs enfin en tout cas les jeunes
joueurs d'ici sont en pleine progression
ils ont tout approuvé et il faut qu'il
ouvre les parties à fond l'objectif de
standard c'est quand pour eux de
progresser et de s'affronter au meilleur
joueur du monde donc une nul sans
intérêt je pense me servirait
pas à grand chose oui oui aucun intérêt
bon après ils peuvent aussi gérer leur
entrée dans le tournoi ça on sait pas
quel est le contexte psychologique mais
en règle générale ces joueurs se
bastonnent quoi mais ils ont bien raison
donc tout ça pas encore ça pas encore
démarré visiblement je pensais que
c'était 14h comme tout le monde je vois
que dans le chat il y en a qui nous
disaient mais alors
je pense qu'il y a un peu de retard donc
donc on va on va attendre on aura la
caméra sauf des joueurs de toute façon
donc là je suis en train d'essayer de de
si vous voulez je peux vous mettre une
caméra j'en ai une qui marche qui marche
à peu près je peux vous essayer de vous
la mettre alors je déconnecté
[Musique]
100 minutes pour les 40 au premier
groupe on est à 1h40 pour les 40 ans
et le statistique c'est vraiment la
cadence à 200 pains à chaque fois c'est
une cadence qui est assez rare
maintenant il y a raccourcissement des
cadence on voit une heure 40 ou 1h30 +
30 secondes par jour pour les 40
premiers coups en règle générale ensuite
un rajoutant d'une demi-heure plus de 30
secondes partout pour finir la partie ça
c'est la règle générale le tata j'ai mis
1h40 pour les 40 premiers coups et 50
minutes pour les 20 coups suivants ce
qui rajoute
énormément de temps et enfin 15 minutes
pour le reste de la partie donc à partir
du 60e
il y a toujours le rajoutant 30 secondes
donc les parties peuvent être très très
lentes quand j'ai démarré les échecs
stouf la cadence il y avait pas les 30
secondes par coup ce qui montre que je
suis un dinosaure du jeu mais toujours
est-il que c'était en Coupe de France
une cadence un peu similaire tes 4
heures chacun 40 coups deux heures une
heure 20 coups et 1h ko ça faisait des
parties de 8 heures maximum minimum
alors qu'aujourd'hui on va dire que ça
se tend à 5-6 heures maximum et là avec
le tata cils ça peut aller un peu
au-delà stuff c'est clair donc là on a
des parties quand même je pense qu'on
attend à peu près
6 7 heures de jeu par ronde ce qui est
ce qui est normal donc oui moi quand
j'ai commencé les échecs c'était pas
comme ça donc je suis pas un dinosaure
je suis un petit dinosaure si tu veux
moi j'ai commencé c'était la cadence
2h40 coups puisque une heure ko tu vois
donc ça pousse la salle de jeux est-ce
que tu l'as mis sauf que j'ai vu les
commentaires peut-être que tu l'as dit
mais j'étais en train de parler des
cadences et apparemment ils entendent
ouais j'ai vu ça dans le chat je suis en
train de j'étais sur une autre page en
plus pour pour donner les cadences et
oui c'est bon oui c'est ok bah écoute
c'est bizarre parce que c'est bon non
non c'est bon excuse-moi mais ça a été
ça a été tu as été trop bon tu as réglé
ça trop vite ben non en fait j'ai rien
fait parce que chez moi j'ai le micro
qui sont coupés donc je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est passé il s'est passé un truc
donc du coup du coup oui non voilà on
voit regarde scène qui qui serre la main
de son adversaire donc les one Aronian
et la partie qui commence par des quatre
du coup
et à tokyras qui qui me dit que je ne
suis pas si vieux et je me demande s'il
a pas le même âge que moi tocasse salut
Mathieu donc du coup on aura le on aura
le plaisir aussi et l'honneur de
d'accueillir tocards Mathieu cornette
lors de la troisième et quatrième ronde
de ce de cet événement
voilà Mathieu cornette qui est grand
maître que vous connaissez pour la
plupart en image je connais je pense
voilà et du coup
tu es mon bourreau dans les catégories
jeunes parce qu'il gagnait tout le temps
je suis pas de France dans ma catégorie
stouf et comme je ratais mes cheveux
étrangères j'avais même pas l'occasion
de l'affronter à l'époque voilà voilà
comment ça se passait mais
très très régulier au niveau du
chauffage
Mathieu multiple vainqueurs et il a
réussi à gagner aussi le chauffeur de
France en toute catégorie et ça c'est
encore autre chose voilà d'ailleurs ça
partit modèle contre contre
[Musique]
dans mes parties de référence sur cette
ligne avec le petit bon il avait joué un
fou c'était un fou gs5 qu'il avait joué
hyper bon il y avait eu un fou au cas de
la très fort avec un bref tomber la
partie je la connais par cœur si tu veux
savoir d'accord ouais bah moi j'étais
plutôt étonné
mais c'est vrai que dans cette partie il
avait joué la ligne E prend des sites je
préfère quand même c'est prendre des 6
pour déséquilibrer un peu cette variante
d'échange qui est très très pénible donc
voilà bon c'est c'est des choix mais en
tout cas ça lui avait pas porté bonheur
à Christian ce choix contre Mathieu
qu'il avait durement sanctionné dans
cette partie
voilà
et oui stouf c'est un peu logique au
niveau de la retransmission avec les
mesures antitrich on a eu on a eu quand
le chat et c'est vrai que j'ai enfin
percuté quand j'ai vu le message donc
merci merci à ceux qui nous réveillent
avec normandus qui nous disait bah ouais
il y a peut-être 30 minutes 15 minutes
pour la mesure antitriche et évidemment
il y a il y a ces 15 minutes et tant
mieux d'ailleurs pour le ouais essayez
de mettre un climat serein autour des
compétitions de haut niveau échec
de délai en fait avec avec les caméras
et aussi et aussi les parties donc c'est
pour ça que du coup
on a eu un petit retard mais on aurait
pu quand même anticiper Kevin
[Rires]
on a une position de catalane assez
assez classique pour l'instant stouf
puisque j'ai déjà joué cette position
avec les Blancs et avec les Noirs donc
bah rien de rien de nouveau
dame c'est de A4 etc c'est du classique
et le fousset 8 en fait ce qu'on peut
expliquer on est dans une ouverture
catalane qui est l'ouverture privilégiée
de Magnus Carlsen le fougé 2 est censé
dominer le fou c'est 8 qui est bloqué en
règle générale et là les von a rognan a
joué quelque chose d'archi archi
classique fouder cette suite fous et 6
pour essayer d'équilibrer le débat sur
cette diago mais les cavaliers B8 est un
peu coincé le pion C7 peut pas jouer en
C5 pour casser le centre donc c'est des
petites concessions qu'il va falloir
gérer avec les Noirs les Blancs sont
tout de suite un petit peu mieux souvent
des positions à du résultat qui sortent
de la Catalane ou les blancs en petit
pressing sur le long terme j'avais une
partie comme ça il y a très longtemps
c'est une partie de Adams avec les
Blancs il me semble ou en fait il y
avait fou gs5 qui avait eu H6 alors pour
te dire la vérité je ne suis pas
vraiment adepte de ses positions ni côté
de l'autre côté noir je connais pas je
suis pas vraiment un expert mais la
partie que j'avais vu c'était un H6 qui
avait été joué par les noirs qui avait
été en fait une grosse faute pour en
fait à cause du gros le casse blanche
plus tard
donc il y avait eu des pleins de plein
de manœuvres et je crois qu'il y avait
eu plus tard un fou qui était parti en
C2 pour ma tech Dame des droits c'était
une partie
d'école vraiment qu'on a que j'avais vu
c'était quelques années et du coup la
question c'est est-ce que on joue ou pas
H6 parce que H6 ça a vraiment d'être un
coup passe partout
mais en fait sur le long terme c'est
vrai que la case blanche autour du Roi
peut être un petit peu faible donc
tu vois acheter c'est un coup comment
j'aurais tempo en blitz
sans me soucier des problèmes extérieurs
mais en fait je sais pas du tout si donc
ok est-ce que tu peux me dire si H6
c'est une idée
en allemand je sais plus ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas joué ça sauf
comme comme position c'est encore en
plus très théorique
[Musique]
malheureusement bon alors je pourrais
dire à c'est facilement en reprenant mes
notes dans les bases de données ça
serait plus simple pour moi
mais on a dit qu'on commentait 100 donc
on va on va s'y tenir
oui bon les thématiques de la position
pour pour les blancs bah ça va être un
monde jouer cavalier E5 de presser de
coincer l'adversaire et on voit souvent
en fait effectivement comme tu le dis
fou prends un F6 c'est un coup c'est un
coup qui se joue derrière avec des idées
de cavaliers E5 donc position pour moi
assez assez naturel et est-ce qu'il faut
jouer à schisme maintenant pour le
provoquer
bah je sais pas c'est tout
des cinq C5 c'est une réaction assez
logique ça c'était le plus le plus
classique mais par contre bon H6 existe
forcément avec avoir les BD7 oui voilà
apparemment H6 pour jouer à 5 cavaliers
à cavaliers à 6 et venir sur casback qui
maintenant est à faibli après le coup à
4 qui a été joué donc après c'est voilà
ça c'est c'est hyper théorique donc à
rognon et cette pollution a eu de la
connais il a déjà joué sans un peu parti
là-dessus et juste en fait là il est en
train de choisir un petit peu la
position qu'il soit avant cette partie
parmi toutes les possibilités donc lui
il est parti ne vous inquiétez pas à
Rognac
en fait c'est juste les plans se
rappeler des lignes et du coup être sûr
de l'évaluation dès maintenant en fait
mais c'est ça peut aller très loin ce
genre de partie au niveau au niveau
théorique
mais ce qui me ce qui me déplaît un
petit peu stouf c'est la mémoire parce
que j'ai joué cette position plusieurs
fois bon c'était 2010-2012 c'est il y a
10 ans et du coup c'est vrai que comme
je suis moins joueur effectif j'ai peu
d'élèves qui jouent la catalane et
c'était une des ouvertures que j'aimais
bien joué pour le petit plus sans risque
et on voit bien la tête des positions on
voit que avec les Blancs on peut
respecter facilement tous les principes
on va pouvoir jouer ksc3 tourner un tour
c'est un par exemple pour pour les
joueurs amateurs c'est vraiment une
super une super ouverture qui qui est
posée et facile à jouer quoi
c'est du grand classique
intermédiaire ça n'a absolument rien à
voir tu sais que j'aime bien faire un
petit truc intermédiaire avec qui n'ont
rien à voir
j'ai mon voisin qui fait les travaux en
haut est-ce que
est-ce que vous entendez un petit bruit
des fois il y a eu un tout petit peu de
marteau j'ai entendu un petit peu de
marteau ça reste un peu ça reste assez
discret
depuis ce matin moi il m'a réveillé je
te dis moi aujourd'hui je me suis un
petit peu tard et je me suis fait
réveiller par les matos par les marteaux
j'avais envie de monter chez lui direct
et il ne s'arrête pas donc ça met de
l'ambiance c'est cool mais non je du
coup ce que je vais faire c'est que je
vais me mute et que dès que je prends la
parole et ben
j'allumerai le micro non mais ça va ça
va c'est pour l'instant c'est pas trop
trop
[Musique]
il y avait quand même quelque chose
d'important dans on a le temps là quand
on était plus speed au cheval du monde
de Blitz champion du monde de Rapids
c'était pas c'était pas si évident que
cela mais ça donnait quoi ta
moustiquaire
tu cherchais une moustiquaire pour
n'allez pas se faire dégommer par ton
chat globalement c'était le projet et
on n'a pas eu le fin mot de l'histoire
est-ce que
en fait alors pourquoi je voulais être
moustiquaire mais en fait si tu veux que
j'ai j'ai été attaqué par une une sorte
de
comment tu peux appeler ça une
sorte de plus ou moins dégât des eaux
via mon voisin du dessus en fait il y a
une qui a une terrasse en fait et au
dessus de la terrasse et ben je me suis
pris vachement d'humidité par rapport à
plein de choses qui sont massées et du
coup mon voisin qui enfin mon proprio
qui m'a dit que c'était à cause du fait
que j'aurais pas les fenêtres parce que
j'avais un chat du coup je lui ai dit
mais moi je demandais de d'installer une
moustiquaire pour pouvoir pour le chat
quoi et il m'avait dit oui du coup moi
j'avais un peu traîné à le faire etc et
du coup toute l'histoire de la
moustiquaire qui pendant tout le tournoi
je peux du monde et ben interfacé et ma
figure-toi que j'ai relu mon j'ai revu
mon mon proprio il y a il y a quelques
jours
qui m'a vu avec le matériel que j'avais
acheté pour installer la moustiquaire et
il m'a dit non mais tu mets pas de
moustiquaire
et du coup c'est une blague enfin il
m'avait dit que je pouvais le faire tu
vois et tout j'ai tout acheté pour le
faire il me dit non et du coup voilà de
toute façon je pars je pars d'ici un
mois
j'ai tout acheté je l'ai je l'ai pas pu
l'installer mais je vais déménager là ça
y est
c'est pas des conditions pour pouvoir
lire en fait je suis infesté de
d'humidité j'ai acheté un appareil de c
pour
[Musique]
ça en fait et je peux pas vivre
là-dedans le mec qui s'en fout il me dit
que c'est de ma faute alors que enfin
juste
c'est n'importe quoi et du coup est-ce
que est-ce que tu as trouvé un autre
appartement non je suis en train de
chercher mais je vais je vais sûrement
revenir sur le continent
je sais pas encore où mais bon je reste
en Espagne je pense par contre
ok ok mais on verra on verra
si vous habitez en Espagne et que vous
avez une petite appartement pour pour
tout mais attention à l'humidité plutôt
un appartement je cherche un appartement
si vous entendez des choses un
appartement hyper bien loyer modéré
voilà ce qu'on veut et je veux trois
chambres
voilà s'il vous plaît
ok bon du coup c'est le coup qui a été
joué on a ces cinq qui va sûrement entre
le coup
on s'est occupé de mettre le fou sur la
diagonale le fousset 8 sur la diagonale
du fou G2 et maintenant on va pouvoir
faire C5 parce que il faut savoir que
ces 5 est souvent possible dans la
Catalane très tôt mais il ne faut pas le
faire s'il faut est en C8 dominé par le
fou G2 c'est une des un des grands
classiques qu'on apprend dans la
catalane et là c'est différent
on va pouvoir mettre en place les
thématiques à base à base de C5 entre
autre chose
d'ailleurs c'est 5 ici est-ce qu'on
prépare ou est-ce qu'on joue directement
parce que ce qui se passe sur des
Français 5 ouais on va le préparer je
pense
peut-être qu'avec des 7 en premier et
éventuellement torcer vite s'il le faut
mais c'est 5 va être sûrement du coup
l'idée joué par bon
des fois on doit pouvoir
[Musique]
faire [ __ ] F3 C6 aussi cavalier assis
ça doit pas être si mauvais cela en tout
cas j'ai déjà joué des positions qui
ressemble bon si on peut éviter c'est
mieux
une des thématiques aussi avec les
Blancs on sera de faire KST 3 pour jouer
pour E4
voilà donc
j'avais des positions comme ça
c'est du grand classique de poser la
question à la dame
parce qu'elle a pas de top case
et salut arpadello salut Fatou qui se
demande pourquoi trois chambres
petit loyer dis pas de métal
non en fait moi je veux une chambre pour
pour dormir quoi et un bureau quoi pour
travailler déjà pour moi c'est quelque
chose que qui est important et puis
après une chambre d'amis mais ça c'est
une option quoi
je pense que ton voisin il est aussi
bricoleur que moi donc pour accrocher un
cadre sauf tu vois il galère le mec tu
vois il est il est pas bon il est pas
bon du tout c'est clair
je te passerai des trucs hier soir avant
de me coucher franchement depuis hier
soir
c'est l'enfer c'est juste l'enfer
peut-être que c'est remerciements d'un
côté ou de l'autre mais il se passe des
choses bizarres là-haut en tout cas
[Musique]
et non en Bretagne il y a vraiment pas
de problème de moustique on est peinard
de ce point de vue là
donc finalement il y a eu tous les tout
à l'heure Mathieu qui était un chat nous
avait proposé les petites thèmes de la
position et finalement ils sont tous
revenus aussi avec ce H6 tout fin bon
pour poser la question au fou G5 qui n'a
plus d'autre choix en réalité s'il y a
toujours des choix il y avait 4 mais
c'était assez logique de faire [ __ ] un
F6
et maintenant on a disposition un coup
comme cavalier C3 qui pense à ce qui
semble assez logique pour inquiéter le
four 4
et bien sûr sur foo prend un F3 on
pourrait alors faire [ __ ] en F3 et
attaquer le pion B7 parce que sinon on a
notre pion des 4 en l'air
donc
ça c'est logique un décès de mettre la
pression comme on le disait sur l'aile
dame des des noirs et le fouger 2
braquer sur la dame pour cela il faut
virer le faux 4
ok ces trois là c'est légitime donc et
cette fois tu penses que il va y avoir
[ __ ]
possible aussi parce qu'en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que vous l'avez vu si on
prend un F3 c'est les fous de couleur
opposées donc à très haut niveau sur un
jeu bien technique des des deux joueurs
bah c'est c'est assez égalisant
donc tourner
il me semble que la partie que j'avais
vu donc encore une fois moi c'est par
rapport à ma référence c'était il y
avait eu un truc de style ça ou en fait
au final avec le courage 6 qui avait été
joué et ben c'était Adams qui avait les
blancs qui avait réussi à
il avait tourné les pièces un petit fou
regarde Dame des deux le fousser2 Dame
des trois tu vois il avait mis des
petites batteries là-haut bon sur le
long terme il y avait plein de manœuvres
il y avait eu du canal de 4 qui était
revenu en D2 en C4 qui avait fait un peu
le tournage et au final ça avait été une
partie que j'avais bon je crois que
Adams a perdu la partie il a blender
complètement alors qu'il était
complètement gagnant je sais plus compte
que c'était mais
excusez-moi je reviens
[Musique]
en tout cas ouais on voit que la
position que nous amuse tout fait elle
est beaucoup plus agréable à jouer avec
les Blancs maintenant est-ce que ça va
être suffisant bon ils ont pas encore
joué ça il y a aussi la possibilité de
garder les pièces ce que nous indiquait
Mathieu qui a été joué dans la partie
bah c'est le fait de conserver les
pièces de mettre un petit peu plus de
pression on interdit tous les motifs
accès 5 vis-à-vis de tour d'âme et
tactiquement protège le pion des quatre
absolument pas comestible sur des cas
parce qu'il y a le vis-à-vis toujours
tour d'âme voilà donc ça va être ça va
être assez
un moment assez important de la partie
de voir jusqu'où les deux joueurs vont
aller dans la théorie pour savoir si
Levana rognons arrivent à égaliser tout
de suite la position ou non
et Mathieu qui a joué blanc noir cette
position encore plus loin évidemment que
nous avec stouf nous dit bah ouais c'est
c'est le petit plus blanc forcément
toujours un peu plus facile à jouer
c'est position de catalane voilà et
salut patoche
bah nous ça va ça va très bien il est
mieux je le vois il a il est un peu plus
fâché que d'habitude je peux vous le
dire
pas contrôler ça quoi
mais malheureusement
quand ça arrive c'est
donc dès que ça ça devient trop bruyant
je me mute du coup je ne parle plus
donc pour l'instant c'est de regarder
sur la base de données si je retrouvais
la partie que je connaissais la seule
particulière
ça m'intéresse parce que ça c'est la
position je l'ai en fait dans la base
mais ok à 5 très logique cavalier A6
cavalier B4 c'est
c'est normal d'aller fixer la structure
blanche à l'aile d'arme et le pion A5
qui contrôle akk et B2 et on s'offre la
case B4 tandis que la case B5 pour les
blancs au pire on aura le petit C6 donc
c'est pas tout à fait la même histoire
c'est très très naturel
c'est sûr que ça c'est égalise en cette
position de toute façon mais bon ok
c'est pas on peut on peut voir après
forcément si Magnus se joue ça c'est
qu'il a qu'il a des idées il joue pas ça
dans le désert plutôt total il joue pour
gagner toutes ces parties donc là on est
assez on est assez peinard
de ce point de vue là ça va être assez
intéressant
[Musique]
il peut pas il peut pas chercher nul
avec les Blancs
on peut repasser vite fait si tu veux la
partie plus le début donc c'est une
ouverture catalane donc c'est un
gambidam si tu veux où on a mis un
fiancetto roi blanc en place voilà donc
est-ce que tu es d'accord qu'on fasse
une petite review depuis le début de
comment on est arrivé à cette à cette
position
tu dois être tu dois être mieux tu
penses que je t'entends excuse-moi oui
j'ai oublié de me
mal j'ai mis du temps à avoir du coup
non j'ai retrouvé la partie que je
cherchais c'était elianov Adams bielle
2015 et c'était un peu le même genre en
fait ici à la place de jouer fouger 5 il
y a eu directement cavalier C3 avec fou
prend fou prends et c'est 6 et
et voilà quoi
et après il y a eu bah le 3 H 4 enfin
casse blanche avec le H6 parce qu'il y a
eu un fou G5 H6 un peu comme dans la
partie quoi et les neuf qui a donné une
grosse leçon stratégique à Adam sans
cette partie et à la fin qui a blender
et qui a perdu mais grosse partie en
tout cas pour ceux qui veulent y jeter
un œil du coup on va quand même aller
voir ce qui se passe sur les autres
parties alors malheureusement un pour
les caméras et ben chez moi j'en ai que
trois alors que j'en avais 17
qu'on m'a donné sur James cam sur les
petites commandées j'en ai que trois qui
marchent donc du coup on va rester sur
45 je pense niveau des caméras et on
peut aller voir ce qui se passe sur
carvana guéri si vous voulez
donc une petite rétine Cavalaire 3D 5 ça
a changé un petit peu après
C4
donc finalement c'est une sorte de début
goût et vite
qui ressemble à un accepté en fait au
niveau des motifs
puisque on retrouverait facilement la
position du Gambie d'un max accepté
après D4 faut baisser enfin faut baisser
de D4 et les idées avec C5 ça serait ça
serait un gamin accepté avec E3 avec un
cavalier C3 sortie peut-être un petit
peu prématurément donc
[Musique]
quel salaire tout à fait tout à fait
normal cette position pas hyper
inquiétant l'idée qu'on revient en
E2 dans ma façon il n'a pas trop le
choix il pouvait pas il avait pas la
case D3 soit on fait des quatre ou des
trois dans ces positions là si on peut
là il n'avait pas le pion des 4 bon
quelle est la prépa peut-être des idées
de cavalier 5 fois 3 avec le fou en 2
ça peut c'est un motif qui existe et de
jouer sur le pion arrière en S7 mais le
pion arrive en C7 il va pas rester là
toute la partie normalement il va se
retrouver en C5
on va pas le laisser ce qui est bien
dans ces positions pour les Noirs c'est
que sur A4 tu as toujours B4 qui attaque
le cavalier C3 c'est pour ça que par
rapport à ce motif de A4 qui est souvent
intéressant pour déglinguer la structure
à l'aile dame là ça se fait moins bien
se trouve c'est pas si facile ok normal
et on peut déjà prévoir C5 x 7 ou fous
des 6 et petit rock on a vraiment un
développement assez simple avec le noir
je sais pas trop ce que veut ce que veut
obtenir Fabiano Kawana
qui a quasiment pas dépensé de temps
pour cette position donc il doit vouloir
quelque chose
mais pour l'instant je ne sais pas ce
qu'il souhaite voilà
ouais donc pendant que tu parlais je
suis en essayer de voir le
voir les options pour enlever mon bruit
parce que c'est un supportable je te
passe sur une autre partie si tu veux
on va aller voir un petit peu
[Musique]
égalisé mais il a il a pris du temps
enfin au carbone réfléchit pas et guéri
a pris un petit peu de temps donc est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment des menaces
stratégiques bon elles sont assez
obscures pour le moment on verra en tout
cas je suis pas trop fan de ce qu'a
obtenu car wanna pour être tout à fait
franc
donc là on a eu une ouverture ouest
indienne alors
la West indienne c'est vous connaissez
peut-être la Nimzo indienne avec
cavalier C3 très rapidement au troisième
cours après avoir jouécartes C4 je peux
pas bouger les pièces hein en train de
faire un petit réglage sinon on
montrerait l'ouverture et
du coup on est parti voilà merci du coup
voilà position de Nimzo et cavalier F3
B6 c'est la position de la West indienne
voilà qu'on ne joue pas sur cavalier C3
sinon il y aurait E4 donc ça n'existe
que sur cavalier F3 ce coup de la West
indienne et ici il y a deux coups les
ventes A3 où G3 il a choisi G3 et on
retrouve finalement on est proche de
l'ouverture catalane de
Magnus tout à l'heure donc c'est tout à
fait théorique le Fou vient mettre la
pression sur le pion C4 parce que le fou
F1 va partir en G2
donc B3 c'est normal on tient on tient
le pion C4 voilà et fou B4 échec pour
essayer d'enfoncer légèrement
l'adversaire et de le désorganiser
petite manœuvre sur foudé deux on ramène
le fond
et on gène légèrement le développement
des pièces blanches le fou amant devrait
rebouger en F4 fou G2 a été joué bon
c'est extrêmement logique
il n'y a pas de menace tactique parce
qu'on a toujours C6 ou D5 sur fulg2 où
j'ai deux qui a été qui a été joué là
petit rock petit rock
normal
D5 a été joué
et là donc il y avait toujours pas de
pour l'instant de découverte mais là
c'est rigolo il y a eu cavalier ces
trois de jouets
tu dis pardon sauf excuse-moi
exactement oui c'est ce que j'étais en
train de regarder donc voilà il y a ce
cette diagonale et qu'est-ce que l'on
pense de la rendre concrète est-ce qu'on
peut jouer qui cavalier 5
ça ça va être ça va être à voir
c'est la question est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on peut sacrifier notre tour
alors ça a l'air de quasiment perdre
direct avec mes
cavalier et la tour sera dur à défendre
il y aura une grosse pression et d'un
point c'est un sacrifice de qualité qui
est assez standard Kevin dans ce type de
position ou en fait on ramasse tous les
pions centraux oui je reste souhaité
gagner ton fou mais là je peux pas donc
effectivement
gagner deux pions pour la qualité c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup mais c'est mieux
si on peut vivre 15 branche c'est ça
c'est ça mais du coup bon en tout cas
c'est intéressant Google qui qui est un
joueur qui est quand même très bien
préparé on l'a vu lors de cette
alentours qu'il était franchement assez
enfin je pense je trouve en tout cas
qu'il est très bien préparé on avait vu
des parties qu'on avait commenté l'un
pour lors de notre interview avec avec
lui parti des Olympiades et il a
toujours on va dire une nouvelle idée
quand il joue
donc c'est intéressant tu vois qu'elle
va laisser 3 qui qui est bon je pense
que c'est le jeu quand même c'est ce qui
fait quoi
dans le désert alors contreding donc
intéressant et tu vois c'est que Ding tu
dois on en a parlé un peu de son de ses
préparations et de ce qu'il va nous
sortir sachant qu'il va je sais pas du
monde ici quelques mois et tu vois que
au final il joue West indienne qui qui
est une petite surprise entre guillemets
tu vois
donc
voilà c'est pas très étonnant je pense
au final passe
très solidaire dans son choix noir la
ouest ça reste du béton armé pas facile
à retourner
on est obligé de jouer du G3 fou G2 bon
enfin ça reste quand même
tu es parti qui qui vont se jouer sur le
long terme c'est pas un E4 premier coup
et on ajoutera on est vraiment arrivé
dans dans un des quatre un peu plus plan
et digne à pas chercher à embrouiller
Google il veut bien placer ses pièces
il doit réfléchir ici je pense
pour des Français 4
[Musique]
et à donner donner la qualité contre de
pions est-ce que sur des points C4 il y
a d'autres alternatives que cavaliers 5
parce que je pense en tout cas tu peux
pas reprendre ici parce qu'il y aurait
faut prendre
par exemple juste je monte l'idée
d'essayer de faire ça maintenant
attaquer le fou mais le fou va venir en
dessin donc c'est peut-être pas l'idée
du siècle bon je gagne la paire de fou
ceci dit mais est-ce que ça va suffire
en termes de contrôle je sais pas sûr
donc je pense que cavaluation canne a
l'air d'être le coup numéro 1 dans la
position
[Musique]
avec le la Tour Eiffel qui sera en prise
donc je sais pas
il est obligé d'évaluer la position il
sait pas si vous cache le bluff ou non
c'est à dire que s'il ne connaît pas il
est obligé de
[Musique]
ou peut-être simplement il connaît il
veut se rappeler des variantes enfin il
y a plusieurs scénario possible mais en
tout cas vous voyez que ça manque
critique d'accepter
finalement ce cadeau qui n'est pas
vraiment un cadeau réel en tout cas ce
gros changement de position il est
vraiment obligé de réfléchir pour
prendre la décision et par ailleurs toi
tu sais peut-être il y a pas des lots
qui nous demande sait-on si dépôt un
gros tournoi de prévu avant le
championnat du monde
pas que je sache
pas que je le sache on va laisser un
vestiger peut-être que le chat va
répondre
on n'a pas eu le coup arriver au serveur
ah bah tiens
la page et ce qui est arrivé
effectivement donc on n'a pas eu la
variante funky ouais bon mais ça m'a
l'air d'être plus dans l'esprit c'est
compliqué quand même de donner la
qualité j'ai l'impression
ok bon mais bon celle-ci c'est la vente
béton on avait annoncé
et là on menace vraiment de prendre le
pion sans doute dans des conditions
assez incroyables peut-être qu'elle va
le 5 du coup maintenant
en dessin n'est pas stupide je pense
oui
[Musique]
c'est ça serait une staff d'échange
après si je fais c'est prendre et on
n'aime pas avoir le fou G2 coincé dans
la slave d'échange en règle générale bon
c'est pas tout à fait la même position
mais on risque d'avoir un petit peu de
mal sur le sur le long terme dans cette
position normalement avec les Blancs je
souhaite conserver la tension
centrale puisque sur des Français je
peux reprendre du pion B d'un pion
extérieur vers le centre et c'est plutôt
une bonne affaire par contre faut pas
que je le perde donc j'ai est-ce que
cavalier E5 est jouable il faudra
analyser et ça mais il y a les deux
cavaliers qui peuvent aller en dessin et
aussi des Français 4 qui a regardé il
faut juste vérifier que des Français 4
c'est pas jouable parce que c'est une
variante concrète donc bah j'ai envie de
vérifier quoi tout simplement
mais dans celle-là j'échange tout et
tout ces 8 quoi c'est ça le truc
[Musique]
c'est pas forcément je pensais même
jouer celle qu'on avait vu tout à
l'heure tu sais avec ah tu veux rejouer
d'en prendre en fait
quand même une belle répartie
est-ce que tu veux aller voir de partir
on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
je vais dans l'ordre
c'est terrible terrible
des chéquiers
Vincent Kemer c'est une glace là pour le
coup c'est un récit
comme ça
et qui ressemble dans une sorte de
Benoni inversé
[Musique]
je sais que l'ordi tu vois il est assez
la position noire mais à chaque fois que
je joue ça en blitz ou en 3-0 je me fais
toujours un petit peu avoir par les
Blancs qui connaissent très très bien et
voilà cavalier A3 cavalier C2 Benoni à
l'envers où on n'a pas pu autant
maximiser le contrôle du centre avec les
noirs que l'on fait quand on a les
blancs avec le tempo de plus
et du coup c'est assez difficile de bien
contrôler la poussée B4 des blancs qui
devrait arriver un cavalier à 3 cavalier
C2 c'est un peu pénible cette position
ça peut vite prendre l'eau en tout cas
la même position avec Quentin de plus et
alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est moi
pourquoi avec un temps de plus je ne
comprends pas trop trop loin
Mathieu explique
ok d'accord ok ok c'est vrai que
généralement on va quand même plutôt 5
jouets
[Musique]
alors ces positions
et le pion qui est en E6 c'est vrai que
le pion aussi
maintenant oui mais ce que veut dire
Mathieu c'est que je crois que
normalement ils vont aussi mais globe de
cou doit être mieux réalisé c'est
peut-être ça l'histoire
je sais pas si c'est des trois trop tôt
qui a été joué ou quelque chose comme ça
oui non mais en plus il se fout de ma
gueule parce que j'ai commencé sa partie
la partie de de
Google avec les Blancs contre Mathieu
lui-même et donc j'ai travaillé en plus
cette position exprès pour pour
commenter ça
et j'arrive à me à plus me souvenir au
bout de au bout de quelques mois et moi
c'est je suis dur quand même et j'allais
dire c'est parce qu'on a commandateur
maintenant on joue plus beaucoup mais
toi tu joues quand même plus ce stuff
oui oui oui oui
on vieillit voilà faut travailler
faut beaucoup jouer pour être motivé
pour travailler c'est la base
avant de commencer à travailler je vous
conseille de jouer sinon le travail ne
servira pas
faut vraiment faire tout le plus vite
possible après quand on est actif
qu'on a différentes contraintes
professionnelles et autres ben ça
devient de plus en plus dur
mais bon c'est hyper plaisant
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici avec
les Noirs dans cette position est-ce
qu'on essaie de jouer avec quelqu'un le
plus emprise ici en D4 il va falloir
faire quelque chose mais
les thématiques tu vois c'est que si tu
joues E5 à B4
comme thématique faut regarder à chaque
à chaque coup et c'est pas si facile
voilà ou alors je prends et je prends de
la tour enfin bref il y a plein de
schémas et on pourrait très bien
réveiller le fouger 2 qu'on voyait dans
la Catalane de macnus qu'on ne le
foutait 8 c'est la même chose c'est le
même
[Musique]
c'est la même thématique
ouais on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
d'échecs je veux dire on a fait que ça
pendant très longtemps donc oui on reste
on reste comme comme correct on voit des
choses avec
des fois on rate aussi ah oui bon
là au niveau théorique il faut vraiment
être à la page parce que vous voyez
on connaît tout mais en surface pas en
profondeur et dans nos débuts respectifs
avec Souf on va plus connaître en
profondeur et on voit Mathieu grand-mère
dans le chat qui entraîneur actif et qui
reste joueur aussi qui doit se maintenir
à son niveau bah il a la connaissance
large et en même temps profonde quoi
donc du coup c'est c'est les deux et
c'est hyper important pour le
compétiteur des fois on dit ouais faut
pas trop apprendre les ouvertures dans
l'air moderne
trois niveaux c'est hyper sécurisant de
bien connaître ses débuts et c'est
important par rapport à la gestion du
temps tout simplement entre autre chose
ok ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir une
autre position on a dit sur le tout à
l'heure que il y avait rapport qui avait
son corps au centre
est-ce que
amusé pour l'instant dans les parties à
jouer une Vienne Oise à la fameuse
donc viennoise 3
bon il est il est habitué de ses débuts
là en début viennois est-ce qu'on a bien
montré
c'est une sorte de gambiroit on pourrait
dire ça c'est une sorte de grand miroir
mais préparez voilà
un miroir c'est F4 deuxième coup voilà
qui est assez chaud c'est un peu
fantasque on peut croquer s'accrocher au
pion en fait dans les gants miroirs
entre autres choses parce qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de variantes là on
NASDA H4 alors faut être un peu un peu
Fada pour pour faire des quatre même si
voilà pour empêcher d'un match 4
voilà les gars du G5 il y a plein de
trucs comme ça qui existent
entre autres il y a plein il y a plein
de choses possibles ici mais voilà le
grand bédourois c'est c'est un jeu un
peu un peu fantasque c'est pas ou alors
surprise tu vois mais c'est pas un truc
que tu vas avoir dans un répertoire je
pense bien son nom
récemment j'ai regardé une position très
approchante qui est très rigolote si tu
veux je trouve juste pour un petit
délire c'est donc je fais une viennoise
avec ses trois
et sur ksi6 donc pas cavalier F6 mais
cavalier C6 on peut on peut jouer F4
c'est assez rigolo donc prise voilà
normal ça ressemble vraiment à un grand
miroir et là on peut jouer un coup un
peu un peu dingue c'est D4
et du coup avec l'idée de ce que sur
damage 4
on pourrait jouer dans ce cas là deux et
là c'est de la folie totale c'est de la
folie totale mais c'est pour vous
montrer juste parce que c'est un
parallèle avec le Gambier roi qu'on
vient de voir que ben on obtient tout le
sens on a une position de folie avec ce
roi E2 c'est pas du tout les principes
mais ça existe aussi aux échecs et là la
variante il y a des cahiers et des 5
blancs qui menacent et le thème que tu
as montré avec cavalier 3 il faut
prendre F4
c'est un peu douteux au niveau on va pas
se mentir c'est ma médiérophe qui joue
des choses comme ça
qui était d'ailleurs c'est assez marrant
ma média enfin c'était le numéro un
autre catégorie avec Mathieu quand on
allait les deux fois je suis avec
Mathieu je fais du monde ma meilleure
offre c'est celui qui gagnait dans notre
catégorie donc je peux je peux te dire
que c'était très très impressionnant en
mammedia offre et il a des idées qui
sont superbes parce que je remarque dans
la base de données ma mégarav il est
capable de jouer quasiment tous les
ouvertures et il les joue quand même à
son niveau bon plus envie de c'est en
rapide mais en règle générale il est
capable de tout
et ici donc sur des 5
prises qui avaler prend et
moi une ligne
F3 alors attends parce que moi j'ai un
trou de mémoire là j'avais un pote
normal
on joue avec des trois ou D4 mais bon en
fait la viennois se joue plus trop au
niveau
c'est aussi un coup normal pour moi je
trouve non je pense je pensais à Dame de
il y a encore une autre souligne
et ça c'est intéressant
on est dans une rareté dans un début
rare mais en fait c'est c'est une ligne
quand même qui est assez enfin qui peut
on va dire très vite être tactique parce
que la colonne F est ouverte les
diagonales sont ouvertes aussi et du
coup il y a des lignes qui demandent un
peu de précision je crois que dame 2
aussi qu'avec ces 6 qui est dans un
engagement direct
je sais plus exactement pourquoi
d'ailleurs bon il y a le pion 5 en l'air
et il y a des cas et des cartes qui peut
arriver aussi souvent
et il me semble que damelot c'est un
goût mais c'est un coup qui est très
vicieux
et c'est très peu connu d'ailleurs
et d'un F3 ok
on reconnaît bien là sous faculté le
petit couvitieux c'est ça
et du coup F5 alors ok donc
le chat que j'ai balancé sa prépa je
pense qu'il faisait référence à Kai ces
trois kssi c'est et le petit truc avec
mais bon on a pas trop approfondi hein
je pense que tu es assez peinard mais
oui c'est malin c'est malin si tu joues
la Viennoise de jouer ça et dans ce cas
là je t'invite à regarder les parties de
m'améliorov si tu joues la Viennoise et
il y a une souligne qui existe qui est
extraordinaire on a elle est si tu
adores la Viennoise
sous fait ce que je peux montrer un
instant
je vais me rendre ouais je vais me
rembourser un petit peu
la petite dette que j'ai envers lui au
deuxième coup à cavalier F6
il y a un système dont j'avais jamais
entendu parler stouf c'est donc nos
cavaliers F6 cette fois ce qu'on a vu
kssis avec F4 bon l'ajoute des 4
je reviens dans une sorte de partie du
centre je comprends des quatre
dames
donc l'idée de ce début là cette bouger
le fou c'est un grand roquette très vite
donc à SSI c'est le coup normal de tous
les parties du centre alors que dame 3
ici et le coup très populaire enfin là
on peut jouer Dame des trois alors
pourquoi l'intérêt le plan c'est fou F4
grand rock
et on a sorti notre Caillan ces 3% et
cette position elle est jouée par My
millerhov dans la base alors elle est
pas parfaite etc mais honnêtement vous
pouvez si vous regardez bien vous pouvez
mettre des cartons à des joueurs de
cartes 5
donc c'est une ouverture rigolote et
m'améliorof la jouer plutôt en rapide
dans des dans des des tournois de haut
niveau et il a réussi à la coller à des
très forts joueurs du bœuf l'a repris
qu'on a qu'à Moura par exemple je trouve
c'est une des références voilà bon bref
en plus normalement les joueurs sortent
leurs fous en B4 ce qui est pas génial
il faut le sortir en C5 bref je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail mais avec le plan
de jouer grand rock rapide pour ceux qui
sont des joueurs d'attaque vous pouvez
vous régaler avec la Viennoise et la
remettre un petit peu la dépoussiérer la
remettre au goût du jour Richard apporte
lui il la remet au goût du jour avec un
dam F3 un peu plus traduit même si je
vois que c'est en train de partir en
live avec du roi des uns donc
j'imagine et tu sors le
fou c'est un peu bizarre au début
c'est un petit peu comme les variantes
de l'Écossais avec avec avaler B3 quoi
je peux quand même je mon plan avec
grand rock sur le foot éventuellement à
3 et puis tu bougeras la dame plus tard
ou
F4 c'est intéressant parce que même deux
si tu veux comme il y a un vis-à-vis ça
empêche tous les plans à base de dessin
qui sont j'imagine à cette thématique
comme dans cette position pour les Noirs
avant la dame venait en E3 il y avait
très vite une tour qui venait en 8 avec
D5 ça ce qu'on vous montre là c'est une
petite pépite à niveau amateur parce
qu'à très très haut niveau si je donne
ça ben voilà à des joueurs du tata style
ils vont me rire au nez parce qu'ils ont
déjà regardé et ils savent qu'elle
variantes fait mal au système bon c'est
à peu près à l'équilibre j'ai
l'impression mais en tout cas les Blancs
n'ont rien donc ça ne va pas les
intéresser voilà faut savoir que des
seconds font des fois des propositions à
des joueurs du tas de style et les
joueurs regardent ils disent NON je joue
pas ça il y a pas il y a pas assez à
couper pour l'adversaire pour que ça les
inquiète en face voilà donc il y a des
fois des belles préparations qui sont
jetées à la poubelle qui feraient le
bonheur des joueurs amateurs mais que
les mecs refusent de jouer voilà je me
rappelle d'ailleurs d'avoir joué contre
Laurent Freyssinet au top 12 bon
maintenant le Top 12 c'est la division
une française c'est devenu Top 16 il
avait joué une prépa que Magnus avait
jeté à la poubelle il faut te dire que
je m'étais retrouvé face au couz stuff
et ben je m'étais fait déglinguer voilà
et c'est d'ailleurs barbix donc notre
collègue kirbarbault qui a ressorti ça
pour battre facilement à 23 50 il avait
vu comment Laurent m'avait bien
déglingué et il a ressorti cette petite
prépa dans la ragosine avec damséen et
du coup très très malin le gars barbix
il a réutilisé voilà non mais c'est
clair mais oui
il est très sérieux ouais mais encore
une fois c'est vrai que que au niveau 45
il y a plein de prépa qui
qui ne passe pas parce que on est à 18
monde de différence et même plus et en
fait à votre niveau à nous bah c'est
différent quoi tu vois on n'a pas la
même réflexion les mêmes connaissances
et tout ça quoi donc intéressant en tout
cas
et
oui je connaissais la réforme cette
ligne et l'arabique c'est le petit
picker d'idée
oui Freyssinet c'est le second de
Carlson donc souvent Laurent
particulièrement dans le 4 5 il a plein
d'idées et puis pas que d'ailleurs mais
en regardant les parties de Laurent sur
le 4 5 on peut vraiment s'inspirer et
piquer beaucoup de choses et il y a
plein de joueurs un joueur que j'aime
beaucoup à niveau amateur
enfin pour conseiller à des joueurs
amateurs certaines ouvertures je regarde
beaucoup blueborne qu'on voit
régulièrement dans les tournois de haut
niveau il s'approche de l'élite mondial
sans y être toujours invité c'est un
joueur qui tourne à 26-50 27 on va dire
il va essayer de grappiller mais il a
plein d'idées comme il joue beaucoup de
Blitz
[Musique]
voilà on a proposé la petite pépite mais
c'est vrai que la partie contre de
Richard rapporte elle s'est en venue
mais on va regarder ce qui se passe un
petit peu
donc je reviens ici
ok donc F5 je ne connais pas du tout
c'était thématique quand même pour tenir
le cavalier dans dans la Viennoise ok il
y a eu des trois prises D4 donc
peut-être position je l'ai déjà vu ça je
l'ai déjà vu c'est sûr
et
donc histoire des sites d'ouvrir un
petit peu les cases noires donc il y a
eu fou ou deux
d'autant plus qu'elle existe avec
cavalier F3 aussi il y a des thèmes
assez similaires donc c'est vraiment
logique pour l'instant ce qui s'est
passé
et qu'est-ce qui se passe si je peux pas
dépendre de pion juste
je demande parce que je ne connais pas
donc est-ce que il s'en fout en fait
c'est un peu je sais pas j'ai un exemple
dans la française aussi où bah là ça va
me laisser le centre lui ce qu'il veut
c'est avancer il veut faire dame G3 et
attaquer attaquer le roi adverse qui
aura peut-être OK ou j'ai des motifs
avec X5 aussi peut-être qui pourrait qui
pourrait être chaud donc en fait un peu
comme dans un Gambie souffre il s'en
fiche quoi
ok donc
typiquement pour toi ça ouais c'est des
positions
en fait bientôt futur de joueurs de
viennoise
je vais jouer du D42 je vais jouer du D4
d'apprendre des quatre t'inquiète par
contre moi je fais un truc c'est que dès
que je donne une idée
un pote dans une ouverture généralement
je lui demande à la fin de de
signe non mais
royalties
il faut que tu gagnes et du coup
t'inquiète pas je signerai Kevin si
jamais je le place un petit roi E2 un
petit imprompre des quatre un jour
j'ai préparé
de jouer à voilà plutôt 2000 2100 sur le
sur le sur le truc c'est vraiment
intéressant je pense ce que je trouve
surtout sauf dans cette ouverture c'est
que c'est hyper facile à jouer tu as que
deux grandes branches à travailler tu as
déjà un début sur 4,5
et en plus pour envoyer du lourd à
quelqu'un qui est très solide ça peut
être rigolo
un exemple sur le chat
à chaque fois je le dis moi c'est
quelque chose que je dis toujours juste
OK
et maintenant on va avec toutes les
vidéos que tu fais s'ils doivent tous
signer tout tu vas voir des ennuis avec
les arbitres ça je le ça fait juste
ouais je devrais le dire sur Youtube je
pense n'oubliez pas
non mais je garde l'idée pour moi aussi
avec tout ce que j'ai donné en ouverture
mais
au final je vais être bien mais en fait
ouais
ouais c'est ça
quatre coins quatre coins du monde
bon du coup C4 donc il a jamais mangé le
pion il a jamais mangé le pion et parce
qu'il voulait pas perdre imagine des
temps de développement et du coup B4 roi
des 1 du coup ah il veut clairement
garder la colonne F1 je pense aussi pour
pour la tour
et donc qui est quand même
en D1 qui peut plus rocker du coup voilà
l'habitude de le voir une cabane c'est
ça la position fermée au centre donc du
coup c'est pas facile de passer et ben
j'ai un petit cavalier F3 peut-être
cavaler G5 il y a aussi du foie H5 qui
peut être clairement aussi une idée même
du Fou G5 c'est une position qui est
assez étrange et du coup j'aime bien les
positions assez bizarres
c'est très créatif je trouve tout à fait
mais le roi noir c'est problème aussi si
il fait petit rock bah on a nos pièces
qui parlent vers le petit roc qui vont
qui vont aller dire bonjour au roi et
d'autre part grand rock mais il y a la
colonne B quand même qui est ouverte en
même temps il y a que la tour qui peut
se mettre dessus peut-être la diagonale
aussi F3 F3 B7 là qui pourrait qui
pourrait faire mal bref oui il y aura de
l'attaque derrière en fait donc
c'est quand même assez assez intéressant
à entrer qui prépare peut-être le grand
rock vu que c'est ouvert ce côté logique
et tant bien qu'il se met directement
sur la colonne B1 pour en prévention du
Grand rock
donc ok partie très intéressante en tout
cas une partie qu'on va convaincue parce
que elle est assez mouvementée assez
intéressante grâce à un rapport qui a
des débuts quand même assez frontas que
par rapport à la moyenne des joueurs de
très haut niveau on sait que Richard
rapport m'amélia Rohff que j'ai cité
aussi c'est les joueurs Nakamura c'est
les joueurs qui peuvent amener des
débuts fantasques à haut niveau alors
que maintenant les joueurs sont plutôt
comme Magnus à jouer des catalan pour le
petit plus c'est la partie sur long
terme qu'ils ne peuvent pas perdre en
jouant des coûts et qui peuvent des fois
évidemment gagner
c'est dur pour tout le monde ce genre de
position
c'est la folie et à chaque coup on peut
être en danger en même temps si tu veux
une suit pas les principes avec ce roi
des un parce qu'on dit il faut roquet
mais sauf nous a expliqué que c'est
comme un rock à la main c'est tu trouves
un abri que tu as construit toi-même
avec c'est un peu du bricolage mais du
bricolage de très très haut niveau pour
le coup donc on a le droit de tout faire
aux échecs si on comprend ce que l'on
fait en fait le critère numéro un
stratégie c'est sécurité du roi rien ne
nous oblige en réalité à roquer en tant
qu'amateur vous en entendez même les
meilleures pédagogues vous dire de
Rocket parce que avant de faire du
Richard rapporte bah va falloir vous
habituer à Rocket pour comprendre quand
vous avez le droit de ne pas respecter
les principes voilà on apprend et on
désapprend après certaines choses tout
ça
et qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille
voir l'autre partie
[Musique]
yes
on va aller voir sur quand même qu'on
avait tenté de voir tout à l'heure
très fun ta vidéo fake sur Jumba
je l'ai pas vu moi non plus
je ne sais pas de quoi tu parles
[Musique]
ou
il me semble mais c'est peut-être Jo qui
aurait fait quelque chose sur sa chaîne
c'est possible aussi bah en fait on a
fait une seule battle et puis après on a
mis on a mis la vidéo sur
Youtube mais c'est la seule chose que
j'ai fait avec Joachim pour l'instant
donc
c'est pas je sais pas de quoi tu parles
du coup on a typiquement dans la
position vent de Forest West les sauts
un travail fou G2 contre fousset 8
encore une fois
mais on a l'air d'être à peu près
rapidement voir
encore une catalane voilà au début
c'était nimeso transposition de faire
une catalane prix C4 très rapidement on
a tous les thèmes et là le foot c'est 8
est dominé normalement c'est des
positions qui sont agréables pour les
blancs
[Musique]
normalement pour moi stof à dire vrai
les histoires de cavalier E5 C5 c'est
toujours à l'avantage des blancs c'est
un petit peu ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure au septième coup quand les Noirs
ont joué C5 les pions DSS sont échangés
et le fouger 2 de 2 V dominer à partir
de maintenant le fou c'est 8 c'est
encore le cas parce que sur cahier
français 3 il y a pas de fou prend C6
voilà il va y laisser des petites plumes
on laisse les sauts qui jouent pour la
nul puisque là par exemple on pourrait
isoler le pion central c'est une petite
domination blanche je pense que vous le
voyez tous on est un peu mieux développé
et le foot c'est 8 est triste
excusez-moi
salut à toi on en a pas on n'a pas trop
trop parler des mesures anti triche
mais effectivement c'est les 15 minutes
annoncés par tri ce temps
effectivement 15 minutes de décalage sur
les retransmissions sur sur le net
ça c'est
fouille aussi impromptu autorisé
mais du coup ça c'est
c'est ce que nous on sait en termes de
retransmission après sur place il y a
sûrement bah tu vois les j'ai vu il y
avait une sorte de protocole qui était
mis en place assez lourd parce que parce
que les meilleurs tournois ont pas envie
de scandale de scandale
[Musique]
donc inspection aléatoire dans tous les
groupes
voilà déjà ça c'est ça
encore une fois on sait pas on sait
jamais mais
[Musique]
voilà
qui
ok
faut que j'aille voir si je suis pas au
courant les gars
on ira voir ça à la pause
est-ce qu'on va se soit rapidement les
parties qui nous restent il nous reste
pragamanda pas encore regardé ils font
partie du coup ils sont déjà au 22e coup
et je pense que du coup au niveau
préparation ça ça a envoyé
donc on va recommencer depuis le début
un jour pour voir un peu ce qui se passe
donc c'est une grande fell
ation
cavaliers de bon un truc assez
standard j'ai envie de dire tout ça
avec B6 donc là c'est vite
H4 donc H4 qui est hyper thématique dans
ces positions avec l'idée de faire
éventuellement à 5 H6
que se passe-t-il du coup sur 20 H4
peut-être voilà faut que j'ai 5 et on
enferme la dame où j'ai 5 dame là et
qu'avec trois
donc il peut pas du tout aller manger le
pion h
donc cavalier à 5 fous des trois
prise et d'un point d'arrêter manger
donc ça les devoirs je pense que on va
créer il a encore une heure 36 à la
pendule bien sûr ça va être connu
5 cavalier j'ai trois de marcherait plus
à cause de vous prendre des quatre
vraisemblablement ouais
il faut vérifier
que je vais avoir ton rêve 2
et ah mais j'ai tout reprend ancien il
doit y avoir
tous les coins que j'ai au moins ça et
ça aussi
peut-être pour faire une mission
sauvetage de la dame
OK
chaleur vous voyez parce que à la fois
on a une qualité de plus mais tout est
déséquilibré on parlait de bazar tout à
l'heure dans la partie de Richard
rapporte voilà c'est sans doute
théorique donc c'est un peu moins
un peu moins vrai mais en tout cas c'est
dur dur à calculer aussi
ok donc c'est la partie donc il y a un
plomberie
il est vraiment très bien préparé donc
il a un pion de plus et le cavalier qui
est un petit peu hors-jeu la structure
un petit peu un petit peu cassée donc
avoir un peu ce qui se passe en faire un
tour C7 peut être intéressant et voir un
peu comment ça ça continue
mais en pratique j'aime bien les blancs
cette position parce que j'ai quand même
un contrôle de ma position
coup les pièces sont un peu placées
bizarrement tu vois et moi j'ai une tour
en 7ème qui va arriver j'ai les pièces
bien placées au centre et ton roi est
quand même plus ouvert que le mien j'ai
l'impression mon roi en géant il est
assez salé
c'est assez sympa donc
j'essaie de trouver un coup surtout
c'est 7 c'est un peu énervant
vraiment je trouve pas facile bon comme
on voit que on a la jauge et que ça
tique pas
aussi donc tu as envie de faire
confiance aussi
qui n'est pas forcément
simple mais tu as envie de faire
confiance
ou pas trop pensé jusque-là
ce qu'on a le droit de jouer à un coup
de folie comme ça de fou prends un F3
et de jouer sur
sur le fait de d'enlever tout l'abri du
roi
wesh c'est pas trop si je prends la dame
au-delà tour on m'en a vu la jauge
prendre une méchante
ou un échec quelque part mais en fait
pour ce 7 est tellement naturel que je
pense que
s'il ne connaît pas en plus la position
se pose les questions de fou.f3 non
c'est clair tu vas pas comme ça au
hasard quoi
c'est quand même le premier coup qui qui
vient à l'esprit et surtout F3 du coup
parce que ton cavalier F4 va y avoir
et du coup pas la pièce c'est le gros
bazar par contre je peux déjà peut-être
faire nul avec tous ces 8 tours C7 non
ouais
du dôme C2 qui peut arriver aussi
[Musique]
après ce qui est bien avec eux c'est
qu'elle contrôle la sortie par achis
et est-ce que j'ai pas une idée comme ça
qu'il faut que je fasse damash4
[Musique]
mais dans H4 qui conserve le contrôle et
j'attaque des cartes en plus
du coup j'ai pas en fait là il faut que
je fasse des c'est tout en prise 2 mais
du coup je m'en fous
c'est compliqué hein franchement
ah mais attends peut-être qu'il a nul en
fait avec ça
ça et en fait je menace si tu veux en
prise tu bouges le fou je pense à faire
échec et si tu mets le roi avant ici
j'ai du cavalier F5 avec la marche 4 tu
vois en fait il y a des il y a des
tactiques à base de vous voyez un de
cavalier F5 la branche 4 et du coup
je peux sortir à l'ancienne en escalier
comme ça
alors tout à l'heure c'est un peu chaud
mais bon il y a toujours fou B5 là c'est
chaud là ça fait peur
et ça ça bon enfin tu as l'impression
que je viens te chercher quoi
tu vois l'ordi il est pas d'accord du
tout mais
je suis quand même malheureusement
[Musique]
vous voyez les joueurs ils ont pas cette
chance là et nous bon si on fait une
gaffe c'est pas grave on dira qu'on a
pas fait exprès que on peut reprendre
notre coup tant les parties n'ont pas à
cette souplesse là
je vais essayer de te le dire
alors j'ai peut-être tout rêve d'eux que
je viens de voir à l'arrache
tout rêve de c'est pas mal quand même
c'est bien plaisir
la maîtrise totale
échec voilà et c'est vraiment tous les
sens c'est hyper compliqué
bref tout ça pour dire que compliqué
vous voyez bah c'est des choses comme ça
que pragnananda est en train de regarder
parce qu'il a envie de jouer tour c'est
ça je pense dans cette position mais il
est en train d'évaluer F3 parce que 6 g
il a parti perdu et il doit sentir qu'il
y a aussi les perpettes à base de tour
C8 quand même et tout ça donc il est en
train de voir s'il a des chances de
gains si il a autre chose etc
en tout cas il a dit qui qui a une offre
un petit salaire pendule il est assez
serein dans cette dans cette partie
tout impôts et donc Prague qui va devoir
trouver tous les coups pour pour s'en
sortir j'ai l'impression
et si je joue pas ça que je joue dans le
3 juste et que je me dis bon écoute je
défends un peu là et je verrai après
plus tard quoi
qu'elle va être
là à haut niveau ils ont pas le choix
aujourd'hui pour être très fort faut
être joueur universel donc jouer des
parties comme Carlson le fait
aujourd'hui des parties un peu molles à
petit avantage qui va falloir faire
fructifier ou des parties hyper
bordéliques très calculatoires comme on
a ici les deux sont possibles voilà et
il y a un style prédominant pour chaque
joueur mais comme je te dis c'est plutôt
universel qu'il faut être et du coup
avoir tous les styles en sa possession
parce que dans une même partie d'échec
parfois on doit être capable de jouer
pour faire fructifier un petit avantage
et après la partie elle explose
totalement et c'est la bagarre et il
faut répondre présent
de
Prague parce que après un échange de fou
en fait tu vois que le cavalier il a du
mal à revenir en jeu
et
voilà en plus après la prise ça me va
aussi des possibilités que ma tour 7e
et
ça a l'air intéressant en tout cas moi
j'aime bien cette pollution en pratique
ça a l'air plus simple pour les blancs
F3 était tellement forte qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose et avec ce fouet 4
les blancs n'appliquent pas ils essaient
toujours de gagner
sans se prendre le fou pour F3 qui à mon
avis aurait annulé directement avec un
roi très très faible
dans ces conditions oui
je trouve que c'est
c'est intéressant pour les blancs je me
pose la question de ce qu'il faut jouer
avec les Noirs sauf c'est pas si facile
c'est pas simple du tout
un malheur très dur pour les noirs
et bon si on a répondu je pense que
bien sûr comme tu l'as dit mais quand tu
connais pas la position ça fait peur
ça fait peur
j'étais en train de regarder fois 6
tours C7 et je trouve ça pénible
[Musique]
3 logique je pense mais bon
pas forcément
[Musique]
n'aime pas trop est-ce que tu peux
imaginer des G5 tours à chi je crois pas
quand même parce qu'il y a le
je suis un peu gêné avec cette tour
c'est ça tourne leur dit pas du tout
apparemment non
[Musique]
cavalier
tu imagines fait le tour C8 tours c'est
ça tu vas être obligé d'échanger ta tour
quoi
c'est bizarre quoi j'arrive pas à
justifier ce que je comprends pas que
donc vous voyez la jauge nous indique
que les noirs sont mieux et comme sauf
je trouve que le cavalier A5 et il est
hors-jeu donc j'ai pas envie de donner
avantage noir donc on doit rater quelque
chose là
peut-être B5 juste
non
mais
moi ça me parle mais alors les relations
de l'ordi pas du tout pas du tout parce
que
on vous rappelle que tout ce qu'on fait
comme comme analyse on essaie de le
faire on le fait d'avoir son ordinateur
vous avez la jauge mais on a pas du tout
les coups et du coup on on vous explique
un petit peu à ce que nous à notre
niveau on pense un peu
et on fait pas appel à l'ordinateur et
du coup
en fait on pourrait avec sauf par
exemple comme dans les ouvertures
prendre la base de données et vous dire
clairement qu'elle a la vérité de la
position et on ferait des traducteurs
d'ordinateurs en se servirait ben voilà
des ordi pour pour traduire si on était
obligé de vous donner la bonne réponse
précise dans une ouverture ça serait
intéressant mais là pour véritablement
progresser faut déjà apprendre à voir
par soi-même qu'à traduire l'ordinateur
donc c'est beaucoup plus simple de le
faire comme ça et on le fait et en plus
avec tout même pour les commentaires on
s'amuse plus à le faire comme ça si
vraiment on a une question intéressante
des fois on met l'ordi pour vous dire
mon lit dans ce cas là ouais quand c'est
trop chaud
[Musique]
ah ok bon voilà encore une fois ça c'est
peut-être ça du coup
c'est en fait j'ai pas vu la case de
passage par F1 et il faut accepter qu'il
y ait des tours C8 tours C7 et cavalier
géant si j'arrive à mater chaque mais
j'arrive pas à mettre chaque avec la
dame après
à cause de la dame qui clouée et du coup
je préfère échec mais après ça c'est
important
c'est ça qui est hyper chaud
par exemple le roi ici il y aurait échec
du couloir et après une fois que le roi
bouge donc là je suis à droite mais si
je vais sur une autre case et ben il y
aurait cavalange et trois qui va venir
attaquer là et défendre la casachon donc
il y a plus tout rachat en fait et du
coup il faut être malin avec tour et
faim il faut être malin que sur échec on
va sur case blanche pour éviter que la
dame nous fasse un choc donc sur la
colonne F je m'attend donc il y a pas de
souci et après chacun a priori je vais
venir ici et ici quoi on peut pas parler
tout rachat c'est le cavalier est cloué
on n'a pas à cavalier 3 donc si la dame
ne bouge pas le cavalier cloué et du
coup bah on est coincé avec les Blancs
pour pour se sortir du mat mais bon ouf
du départ j'ai pensé au départ aussi
mais en fait tu me NAS juste de mettre
une batterie en place tu sais se trouve
dans la position initiale il voulait
faire G5 tourraîchis
Samsung
tu menaces rien en fait même si tu
arrives à faire dans ma chambre et c'est
très long il faut deux coups dans ma
chambre serait pas décisif quoi donc et
j'ai toujours cavalier j'ai trois au
pire du pire enfin bref même si je peux
même je passe mon tour
parce que peut-être que tu menaces parce
que bon au final
ça fait hyper peur voilà mais juste pour
te dire que si je joue pas en fait il
menace au final pas grand chose
ça existe pas en fait j'ai beaucoup de
façon de pouvoir empêcher j'avais même
du E5 intéressante qui empêche ça après
j'avais plein de coups qui avait l'air
sympa
donc faut 4 c'est hyper hyper
intéressant moi je j'aime bien les
blancs quand même
cette position je trouve que c'est
possible à jouer on disait que le roi
blanc était plus
on disait que le roi blanc était plus
simple que le roi noir mais au final on
se rend compte qu'avec les ventes
combien de devoirs avec Alex et 4 que au
final le roi blanc il est pas si safe
que on aurait pensé c'est de ma faute
sur damascade j'ai joué dame 3 qui est
peut-être un prix mais je t'avouerai que
je trouvais que c'était le coup vraiment
naturel de chez naturel
pour garder la tour ancien du coup mais
c'est trop c'est moins normal
essayez de viser la viser là en disant
que sur dame échec roi là j'avais encore
la marche froid enfin je sais pas c'est
très décidé mais
je fais bouffer le cavalier du coup
il est en prise de cavalier
[Musique]
je crois que c'est
ça ouvre la position si je fais pas ça
ben les blancs vont s'activer
parce que là on a juste joué ça pour ne
pas subir il faut prendre F3 et se faire
éclater le roi bientôt tours c'est ça va
exister
avec des conséquences assez dramatiques
si les blancs tiennent au niveau de leur
roi ils vont éclater la septième rangée
et ça va faire mal
alors est-ce que tu veux qu'on retourne
tu veux voir les parties préférée
personne nous a demandé Magnus alors on
adore aller voir Magnus mais c'est vrai
que d'habitude
et c'est clair on a on a pas de français
non cet événement donc du coup on n'est
pas on n'est pas vraiment de venir
déchiquier important à suivre on va sur
un peu tout le monde je pense qu'il y a
pas de d'ailleurs sur le chat si vous
avez des des parties que vous vouliez
suivre particulièrement ou des questions
ou quoi que ce soit surtout n'hésitez
pas on essaiera de vous répondre avec
avec Kevin
stuff on n'a pas parlé de la jeune
pépite américaine dans le challenger
aussi tu sais c'est le plus jeune grand
maître international on pourrait aller
voir éventuellement
on a le plus jeune grand maître de tous
les temps qui
qui participent au Challenger donc ça
pourrait être intéressant qu'on en parle
un petit peu il y a Rooney qui nous dit
Magnus Magnus voilà ça y est on a
chauffé quelques-uns
qui nous demande si tout à l'heure
excuse-moi voilà que j'ai vu ta question
des fois on voit vos questions après on
les oublie mais il demande si ma tenue
ça a toujours l'objectif des 29 si on
pense que c'est atteignable oui je pense
que si les motivé s'il y a bien
quelqu'un qui peut faire de 1900 et
l'eau c'est lui maintenant faut être
très régulier faut que il y a une
densité de joueurs à un très bon élo
faut qu'il soit en forme voilà il a il a
perdu des points par rapport à son
record il y en a pas si loin mais en
même temps lui c'est une galère pour
Magnus comme il a il faut qu'il batte
digne plusieurs fois s'il avait fidélisé
digne dans un championnat du monde
peut-être mais là c'est quand même pas
si facile mais évidemment au vu de son
talent au vu de son immense domination
preuve en est quand même sauf qu'il ait
gagné en blitzer en rapide pour moi
c'est un marqueur fort parce que manus
c'est vraiment le jeu lent c'est
vraiment le vrai jeu la recherche de la
vérité à chaque coup et puis le fait
exceptionnellement bien non c'est
monstrueux en plus pendant le but c'est
rapide il a vraiment été
au-dessus quoi dans les parties tout ça
je trouve qu'il a vraiment été au-dessus
et clairement pas de mérité ce qu'il a
fait
[Musique]
c'est ouf mais qu'on va la faire
effectivement été peut-être trop
respectueux de Magnus même dans cette
partie là il a il était un peu gêné je
pense de la situation de jouer le mec il
sait qu'il est moins fort il est un
immense respect pour le meilleur joueur
de tous les temps et du coup il fait un
peu une non partie quand même mais
j'ai besoin de gagner quand même
impressionné et un petit peu on va dire
gêné par le fait que car ça n'arriver en
retard tout ça il y a eu des trucs
complètement donc pourquoi mvl et ne
joue pas
bon mvl je sais que que
le cadre du tournoi
il aime pas trop quoi il fait froid
c'est l'heure de se mettre très longue
voilà donc on peut comprendre que mais
est-ce qu'il avait été invité souffre là
actuellement je sais pas mais je pense
je suis pas sûr mais je sais pas je sais
pas vraiment pure supposition j'aurais
bien aimé le savoir quoi tu vois c'est
pas tout à fait pareil
que même lui en fait ça l'intéressait
sinon
[Musique]
férosa il y avait eu un problème inclus
l'année dernière
je passe te souviens on avait eu
on avait eu
c'était quoi c'était il y avait des
partages qui avait lieu entre Guiri et
Van Forest et du coup il y avait fille
rouge qui jouait encore sa partie alors
je sais plus quand c'était entre un
joueur random et en fait il était
gagnant dans la partie et en jack note
et en fait on lui a demandé de
de déménager ça ça tape de jeu pour
laisser place à la partie des partages
sur lequel il était quoi alors qu'ils
t'ont donc lui il a dit maintenant mais
c'est une blague enfin je suis en train
de jouer tu vas pas me tu vois et en
fait du coup
il a fait un scandale et quand il s'est
assis il a blender il a pas gagné et
pour le coup on peut le comprendre
c'est ça pour pour le coup on peut le
comprendre ça c'est jamais
je trouve que la faute de l'arbitre elle
est abusée ensuite bon ok
mais l'organisateur va essayer de le
récupérer quand même marché
il y a peut-être deux ans bon enfin ok
c'est la faute d'une personne c'est pas
forcément l'orga lui-même bon ça arrive
par les erreurs ok bon mais l'idée en
fait c'est qu'après ils avaient proposé
à
une compensation etc et le réinviter
d'après et puis lui en fait je voulais
pas il était fâché et en fait il a écrit
il a dit que c'était trop près quoi il
avait demandé une somme d'argent
vraiment
beaucoup trop importantes comme
invitation et en fait c'est sa manière
si tu veux de de refuser l'invitation
quoi
donc voilà donc du coup c'est donc on
sait pas s'il reviendra un jour
mais en tout cas on verra donc là il
s'est passé des trucs intéressants dans
la partie on voit qu'il y a un carré qui
a été joué attends je vais j'avance un
petit peu il a piqué le pion Magnus il a
piqué le pion à 5
c'est une tactique alors regarde ce qui
se passe dans tous les sens
on apprend à 5 tout simplement et ben je
vais manger alors je sais pas si je
comprends en premier ou pas mais à la
fin le cavalier de cette soirée
derrière donc il y a eu faut prendre sur
ton excuse-moi
c'est comme qui encore buggé des fois ça
me met une erreur ça me l'a déjà fait
plusieurs fois
donc sur cavalier prend à 5
sur ton plan je disais et ben on a qu'à
aller prendre des sets qui va en fait
comme tout à l'heure et déstabiliser un
petit peu les pièces qui sont ici genre
d'un point de 7 je pourrais maintenant
manger la tour
et
du coup il y a eu cinq intermédiaires
mais dépend attaque la tour à 5 millions
donc surcharge la dame
simplement je vais manger ici alors
encore une fois je parle qu'elle a
reconnu
cette ou tourner cette direct moi je
serai plus David manger ici pour avoir
mes pions liés mais après avoir
il y a eu pour prendre un 5 étant en DS7
ici pour pour dévier la dame et manger
la tour à 5 donc 3 4 donc là c'est
vraiment un jeu de bouffe tout hein et
surtout reprendre des 8 et ben il va
manger à
échec et après manger des huit pendant
que ça et cette position ben elle est
peut-être même gagnante pour les Noirs
parce qu'après 31 ça a l'air très très
chaud pour pour
c'est moins clair largement
tout à fait raisonnable même très bien
et moi j'aime beaucoup les blancs dans
cette position parce que j'ai la colonne
des j'ai une tour en 7e
et j'ai beaucoup plus d'espace
j'ai l'impression que les Blancs se sont
très très bien sortis
incroyable en termes de structure ça ok
pour les Noirs mais en termes d'activité
pas du tout par rapport à ouais au
placement des pièces blanches qui vont
vraiment être assez énorme donc on a
perdu la contrôle le contrôle de la
colonne bon on peut pas faire tourner 4
tout ça mais je sais pas moi
j'ai envie de faire tourner c'est la
partie d'ailleurs moi je veux rien faire
parce que ça m'avait l'air tu as
l'impression que le contrôle de la
colonne est vraiment vraiment plus
important mais
bonne gueule aussi ce truc là ouais avec
avec un dame C5 peut-être plus tard
ouais qui a tour des quatre tours
d'abord on contrôlé et puis voilà qui
empêche la dame de s'activer qui empêche
un peu tout une dame des deux c'est pas
débile non plus qui empêche pour des 8
bon il y a toujours le 5 on devra
surveiller l'idée de jouer ça ça par
exemple intéressant
avec le fou la tour le vis-à-vis
ça a l'air difficile à tenir en pratique
donc
avoir ce qui se passe que 45 peut elle
peut nous faire en tout cas il y a eu
d'en prendre des sets pour des quatre
manières assez obligatoire par contre
toujours pas
on vient d'en parler
petit embrouille au statistique il y a 2
ans et du coup il ne veut plus venir
pour le moment en tout cas
ouais en tout cas position à cette
difficile quand même pour les Vona
rognons qui jouent très très vite c'est
le seul la seule chose qui est bien pour
lui mais on a dit que carlossen n'allait
jamais être inquiété à la pendule la 50
minutes c'est une cadence très très
lente donc pas de problème là-dessus
mvl pas invité salut Andy chess salut à
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent en cours
de stream donc première ronde du tata
style avec stouf que l'on commente
pendant une quinzaine de jours Charles
commentateur de du week-end vendredi
samedi dimanche et tout tu vois tu vas
commenter tout le temps tu vas être là
pendant 15 jours heureusement que tu es
là un souffle pour nous présenter cet
événement chaque jour je vais être la
souffle le dernier week-end là je suis
en déplacement
mais tu viendras quand même tu viendras
quand même le dernier jour pour le final
il faut que d'abord il faut que voilà
technique en direct
incroyable aux échecs je vais voir ta
technique
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe
terrible vous savez un petit peu de moi
parce que le dernier week-end comme
stouf n'est pas là
à d'habitude je suis dans un fauteuil si
vous voulez je fais les commentaires on
adore les échecs avec sous c'est facile
et le dernier weekend je dois aussi
m'occuper des caméras de mettre le
stream propre et tout ça et j'avoue que
c'est pas ma partie préférée et du coup
je trouve ça le fait un peu marrer parce
qu'il sait très bien que
ma techniquement mon niveau moi aux
échecs le vélo ça démarre à 1000 le vélo
officiel bah je dis souvent je suis
100010 quoi pour atteindre 1100 mais
maxi enfin entre 2010 et 1100 donc c'est
pas top c'est pas top au niveau de du
logiciel de streaming quoi voilà voilà
voilà toute l'histoire et souffre rigolo
encore hein quand je dis ça je suis
désabusé je suis désabusé et du coup le
dernier jour bah je serai pas chez moi
donc du coup j'aurais pas accès à mon
ordinateur à tous mes à tous mes trucs
donc je pourrais pas prendre le stream
malheureusement
donc donc c'est moi qui vais faire venir
tout dans le stream enfin si j'y arrive
sinon vous pouvez pas tout c'est la vie
va être dur la vie ça va être compliqué
ça va être compliqué
mais on va réussir on va réussir on va
réussir ça va le faire
en tout cas voilà première ronde tu as
silky réunit les meilleurs joueurs du
monde et les grands grands espoirs que
l'on a eu l'occasion de voir au chemin
du monde de l'île championnat du monde
de rapides ben ils sont là ils sont
présents
les gros poids lourds Carsen dingly
Rennes à rognan Guiri karwana bon vous
avez compris c'est du très très haut
niveau et là on voit un Magnus qui va
visser les vannes pendant maintenant des
heures et des heures ils vont pas faire
nul tout de suite
dans cette partie
ouais ouais là il y a un bon petit
travail qui va s'opérer et Magnus est le
spécialiste de ce genre de position
après attention les voilà rognan est
hyper fort mais il doit pas être très
satisfait quand même actuellement non je
pense que sa position c'est pas trop
trop ce qu'il voulait et de prendre un
petit peu alors des coups ont été joué
là ça bug un petit peu chez moi pour te
dire la vérité des fois les couches
n'arrivent pas au serveur il faut que je
que je
après est-ce que l'échange des tours
favorise peut-être
la nul peut-être que c'est possible
mais comme ah oui B4 on aura peut-être
pas parce qu'on a peut-être pas le
timing pour faire dam 5 B4 il y a
peut-être des tours qui traîne va
falloir vérifier tout ça parce que tour
des 8 souffle comme tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure il y avait tour des 6 et assez
agréable
ça fait suite jouer cette position et si
j'ai besoin hk3 H2 quoi c'est ça que je
comptais jouer maintenant faut voir ou
fk3f2 faudra voir faux F3 roi G2 en tout
cas j'ai envie de mettre mon roi à
l'abri et de gérer la crise
en tout cas les temps pour pour jouer
tout cela donc c'est qui doit pas être
non plus
ultra inquiet voilà pour aller dans le
sens
aller dans le sens de de ce que nous dit
Mathieu voilà donc dans le chat ok bon
c'est en tout cas un bon petit pressing
dans le style de Magnus plutôt cool
comment est-ce que tu réponds sans ma
question parce que mon plan ce plan là
c'est fort
est-ce que tour à 8 fait double menace
tourin tour à 5 c'est ce qu'il faut
vérifier
c'est tout à 5 c'est une idée il y a 50
prises
quand même
parce que tu auras cinq au pire du pire
du pire j'ai Dame des 600 donc c'est pas
non plus
donc je sais pas si je dois jouer F4 F3
ou H4 pour mettre mon roi je l'ai 3
cases G2 F2 H2
peut-être bien
malheureusement apparemment il a juste
demandé
ok mais du coup tu retournes
donc ça transposera peut-être que c'est
encore mieux parce que ton tour
d'ailleurs qui va qui va forcer un petit
peu un échange puis on prend
peut-être que c'est plus précis en fait
on décide bon tu vois si le jeu
ok bah ouais et ça il y aurait pas eu
sur dame C5 quand même c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose ok mais d'imbécile G2
H4 on va améliorer la position voir un
peu ce qui se passe c'est noir n'ont pas
grand chose à faire cette façon c'est
plus agréable quand même est-ce qu'un
petit BK
pour être une option une fois que
j'aurais bien tout
[Musique]
pour avoir la case à chatte pour son roi
et ensuite sur cette tentative là faut
faire gaffe que la tournoi fasse pas le
tour avec tout à 8 tour à 5 tours
français 5 fois avant
[Musique]
exactement
donc du coup c'est pas si facile
à aronia de trouver de trouver des
solutions parce que carcennes il y a une
position quand même pépère
donc tout va vite avec les jouets
et donc là moi j'aime bien le petit F3
pour mettre le roi en sécurité vous
savez qu'on n'a pas envie de mettre son
le fouet
H2 je suis pas fan je préfère
[Musique]
c'est un peu mieux donc je pense que
vous F3 va être joué après j'ai aussi
hésité peut-être alors avoir un B4 qui
empêche Damart qui prépare on parlait
d'un MC5 qui est une possibilité aussi
mais après ça peut aussi être une cible
peut-être que plus tard adambicistes
aura 4 ça peut aussi être un problème
donc bon avoir si j'ai envie de bouger
la viande il est intéressant
particulièrement avec ton foie F3 c'est
que sur fogestis tu as peut-être l'idée
H 4 h 5 qui reviendra
[Musique]
si jamais j'arrive à ramener une pièce
en diagonale sur la case blanche et ben
ça peut être intéressant en tout cas
j'ai 6 h en G6 double
noire salut Mister pesso
ça a commencé il y a longtemps ça a
commencé à 14h voilà comme à peu près
mais il y a un quart d'heure de décalage
un quart d'heure de retard volontaire
pour les mesures antitrich comme on l'a
déjà dit et du coup on a dit que des
cadences étaient longues
1h40 chacun
donc voilà on est à plus de trois heures
plus 50 minutes chacun on a encore après
deux heures
donc on est à 5 heures 5 heures de
partie plus 15 minutes ça rajoute encore
une demi-heure plus les rajouts donc
voilà ça peut faire des parties de 6h à
7h maximum on va dire si vraiment il y
avait une grosse finale voilà si cette
heure de partie donc souvent des stream
d'au moins 5 heures on va dire parce
qu'il y aura des jours peut-être ou ça
ira un peu moins loin mais ça dépend il
y a toujours des fois une partie qui
peut qui peut traîner ça dépend un petit
peu de ce qu'on verra sur la fin je
pense qu'on a du 5 5 heures minimum
7h maximum et du 6 heures de moyenne
voilà voilà
le mercredi 18 lundi 23 et le vendredi
ça vendredi
26 un jeudi 26
ils sont habitués faut pas trop
s'inquiéter pour eux c'est vraiment leur
métier c'est l'équivalent des sportifs
de haut niveau de ce point de vue là
aucune inquiétude pour eux ils peuvent
jouer aux échecs tous les jours tout le
temps
on va dire le matin ils font des échecs
ils revérifie ils regardent ce qu'ils
vont jouer
moi j'aime bien les cadences rapides en
fait enfin j'aime bien les parties
lentes mais quand c'est rapide
c'est à dire que là les cadences
interminables comme celle-ci par exemple
moi je ça m'intéresse pas je trouve que
c'est beaucoup trop lent
une cadence avec un rajoutant 40e moi ça
m'a toujours gêné
et moi j'aime pas en fait moi je charge
1h30 plus 30 minutes moi j'aime bien
voilà après c'est 1h30 + 30 minutes non
1h30 ou 30 secondes moi je suis pas de
métal
comment va ta tante
on est copain de cadence patte voilà non
mais en fait non non mais 1h30 par coup
c'est c'est
ma cadence préféré
[Musique]
nous mettre une crasse autant au 40e et
nous mettre du giga pression alors que
moi j'ai besoin de mes 30 minutes
j'avais compris
tu sais que moi plus la partie elle est
longue plus l'essence de Blender parce
que comme je suis un joueur qui joue
vite un peu à la népo mais en beaucoup
beaucoup moins fort et bah du coup comme
je peux blender à tout moment et ben je
préfère qu'il y ait moins de chance de
Blender
c'est moi la cavalence le plus que vous
pouvez
plus de chance de faire un résultat
rigolo ah mais c'est la variété en plus
généralement quand je parle une partie
bon ça m'arrive souvent de par une
partie parce que je me suis fait dominer
ça mais beaucoup de fois par une partie
parce que je blender en fait et je vais
être trop vite un coup et j'ai fait une
bêtise en un coup quoi c'était super
beaucoup de partir au déblenders
riff qui est vraiment un super style
pour mettre la pression mais quelques
fois il fait
des grosses conneries on a quoi problème
c'est ça tous le même problème cette
typologie de joueurs ça met la pression
c'est hyper bien ça provoque les erreurs
chez adversaires mais en même temps bah
ouais il faut aussi pas jouer un coup
trop vite sinon ça peut
ça peut comment dirais-je vous portez
préjudice mais bon quelle est l'équipe
moi je me retrouve mal au temps je
trouve je suis pas mieux enfin je veux
dire ça me saoule d'être mal au temps
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien justement
savoir plus mettre la pression après
est-ce que c'est un défaut patoche
est-ce que c'est un défaut parce que ben
oui des fois ça arrive à mes pots on a
même on a la même vue je peux la demande
de rapide là quand il a perdu contre
qui l'a perdu en un coup alors qu'il
avait une position
assez écrasante et en fait
des fois ça lui arrive de Blender dans
des bonnes positions ou voilà mais le
nombre de parties qui va réussir à
gagner grâce à la pression qui va mettre
donc en fait c'est un style de jeu tu
vois une question d'équilibre au bout du
compte c'est à dire qu'il faut mettre la
pression et pas gaffer en un coup et ni
café et puis là on arrive à quelque
chose de merveilleux vers lequel il faut
attendre mais c'est facile à dire et
beaucoup plus difficile à réaliser
ton on avait le mode d'emploi on le
ferait mais en tout cas c'est pas si
évident que cela
bon est-ce que est-ce que ce serait pas
l'heure de notre pause goûter au fait
sauf
oui oui le petit moment
[Musique]
là il se passe plus grand chose on va
faire une petite pause on va vous
laisser avec une belle pub et on va
revenir du coup ben dans dans quelques
minutes alors attends je vais juste
check mais cette scène de parce que la
caméra ne marche pas donc j'envoie un
petit saut vers ta chaîne stouf vas-y
vas-y je t'en prie allez et
j'espère que je vais réussir du premier
coup ce qui est pas non plus sur à 100%
c'est que des fois je peux faire des
blagues techniquement voilà on fait
comme ça vous avez double pub mais au
moins vous pouvez choisir d'aller voir
on va voir un petit saut vert tout
est-ce que ça a marché ce que j'ai fait
je me suis gouré
[Musique]
sauf tu me diras ouais une petite
seconde
je dois c'est bien de ce que j'ai fait
tu as fait ce
pas les gars en pâte
on est raisonnable les frenchies
voilà j'ai préparé la scène et je
préparé l'autre aussi en fait les
caméras marche pas on m'avait préparé
une scène si vous voulez avec une des
vidéos qui ne marche pas du coup je peux
mettre une autre vidéo et préparer la
scène donc une petite seconde
à la baguette technique je pourrais
l'embêter mais je sais que bientôt je
vais y passer
je sais que techniquement il est assez
merveilleux du coup moi je suis prêt
donc voilà on va revenir dans un instant
quelques minutes histoire de se
restaurer un petit peu je vois que le
sauce touffe il est bien passé
d'ailleurs je vais commencer un saut
vous savez que nous on stream aussi
avec avec Kevin donc n'hésitez pas à
aller voir nos pages twitch nos pages
YouTube etc etc etc donc vous êtes
toutes les infos sur nos liens en tout
cas
donc aujourd'hui sauf c'est le lancement
officiel de ma plateforme dont j'avais
déjà parlé et je vais mettre un petit
j'ai envoyé pas mal de mails aujourd'hui
pour le cadeau pour accéder à ma
plateforme de cours donc je le mets là
pour ceux qui veulent aller voir comme
ça vous avez un petit cadeau de
bienvenue si ça vous intéresse pendant
qu'on n'est pas là avec vous à commenter
n'hésitez pas en tout cas ça nous fera
plaisir à tout faire moi que vous nous
rejoignez sur sur nos chaînes donc faut
pas hésiter
allez on part en pause je vous dis à
tout de suite
ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin
j'espère qu'on vous a pas trop trop
manqué et que la musique vous a bien plu
alors apparemment apparemment il y a eu
vraiment
tu as eu tu pouvais pas tout avoir hein
tu pouvais pas avoir la partie la
musique
Carl c'est dans grand voilà pas tout
avoir
ouais donc du coup du coup oui non nous
les les musiques de pub sachez que que
c'est pas nous qui choisissons on a même
pas écouté moi je l'ai pas écouté et
puis voilà bon en tout cas les parties
ont un petit peu bougé on a eu un petit
tu vois on a eu ce qu'on avait dit on
avait parlé de faux F3 pour mettre le
rang en G2 et du coup de H4 pour aller
l'embêter le fou et puis en H5 et du
coup tout ça ça va forcer à rien à H5
donc logique mais d'un côté tu vois un
fou qui est quand même condamné un petit
peu pour l'instant on va défendre tout
ça c'est une position qui est quand même
assez affaiblie
mais qui est quand même toujours assez
solide pour les Noirs c'est pas simple
faut vraiment de progresser avec les
Blancs donc on peut imaginer un dame de
a peut-être même essayer de le manger
depuis en B2 avec un tour tourin tour B1
par exemple c'est c'est pas simple mais
ok on va voir un peu comment voilà
comment Carson travaille donc on voit
qu'il est encore 33 minutes à la pendule
mais je rappelle que la cadence elle est
elle est ultra lente il aura 40 minutes
dedans 50 minutes de rajout
dans 14 ans voilà c'est ça et ensuite
15 minutes
dans 34 coups
donc beaucoup beaucoup de temps en fait
à
disposition donc c'est cool
alors si on fait un petit tour des
stades un peu comme tout à l'heure on a
karwana contre guéri qu'on a vu au début
on avait dit qu'il a l'ouverture avait
plutôt souri au noir avec une version
assez rapide avec du coup donc il a joué
à 4 comme on avait proposé tu avais dit
qu'un 4 B4 mais Caval et bien
ce qu'on fait les blancs puisque ça fait
si après elle joue avec Descartes ça
sera un mauvais un mauvais candidat avec
des temps moins donc ils vont passer par
des trois mais bon c'est pas c'est pas
très intéressant des trois C5 le pion
des trois est un petit peu faible là
sauf bon ok il y a peut-être des cases
qui sont gagnés mais c'est pas assez le
fou baisser à tes monstrueux
je comprends pas trop ce qu'il a voulu
faire Kawana dans cette dans cette
partie et il avait l'avance autant sauf
qu'il n'est plus le cas donc même lui là
il a eu des problèmes très clairement
ouais donc il a joué à 4 en provoquant
des quatre pour justement pouvoir
ramener le cavalier sur cette case là
c'est cadre
cette thématique mais c'est long de
passer par B1 pour tuer de faire KFC 3
revenir en B1 repartir en D2 c'est long
quand même c'est très long et donc là on
voit un cœur qui donne la case D4 mais
il permet au foot sortir aussi en
E3 donc dame C7 donc là je crois
et quelle est cette photo comme tour
c'est un B3 fixer un petit peu
je sais pas trop comment c'était
peut-être pollution j'ai envie de dire
que les noirs sont ok
c'est globalement égal mais si on devait
choisir un camp c'est plutôt les Noirs
ouais parce qu'il y a un canapé en
Détroit je peux pas trop pousser et puis
T4 c'est pas facile à jouer tu vois ce
serait un peu le coût libérateur mais
c'est pas simple à jouer parce qu'il est
quand même toutes les colonnes questions
ouvertes c'est c'est pas évident
pas fan de la pollution ici de karena
après c'est encore une position qui est
jouable encore des choses possibles à
faire ici mais c'est vrai que que
dans ce genre de position mais disons
qu'on a du mal à comprendre ce qu'il a
voulu de l'ouverture notre ami Kawana
j'ai l'impression qu'il a obtenu
une égalité et encore et encore voilà
donc c'est pas c'est pas une domination
des blancs comme dans les autres parties
un peu modestes avec le fou en G2
tranquille là on n'a pas grand chose
c'est pas très excitant en plus pas de
perspective incroyable
si on compare l'ouverture jouée par
Magnus Magnus a obtenu un petit quelque
chose qui va travailler là si on en est
loin
et comment il passe dans cette position
c'est pas grand chose en tout cas parce
que tu sais ce fou j'ai deux stouf j'ai
un peu de mal alors peut-être cavalier
E5 et une thématique qui existe c'est de
jouer des fois pour E4 mais là il faut
pour l'instant donc ce sera pas possible
peut-être à un moment jouer qu'il y a eu
5 tours je sais pas et c'est de faire
quelque chose en tout cas parce que
juste passer sur la colonne C avec des
pièces un peu mieux placées mise à part
le fou G2 je trouve que c'était un peu
juste pour les blancs ok mais eux prends
des 5 totalement jouable évidemment
il a envie de d'avoir une position pas
symétrique et essayer de tenter le gars
bien entendu je trouve c'est bien dit
parce que les joueurs en pratique ils
veulent jouer aussi et digne et sont
peut-être plus forts comme tu le dis
donc ça sera plus fort après il a les
noirs
donc tu vois eux prend des cinq bon moi
j'aime pas trop trop la structure je me
dis que l'option C6
plus tard ça peut être une cible mais
j'imagine que Jing a d'autres idées
derrière la tête
cavalier un peu bizarre car il y a 5
faisait plus sensible en position mais
j'imagine qu'il va venir peut-être
essayer encore une fois de jouer qu'on
peut penser 6 empêcher la pousser ses 5
je le vois comme ça c'est pas vraiment
bon je reste un petit peu étonné parce
que ça met moins la pression je trouve
tout fait mais bon ok bah il est plus
fort que que moi donc il y a pas de
souci clairement il a dû bien mesurer
les choses
en tout cas
un moment si besoin que ça reste un peu
bon il va se prendre un cavalier là donc
il bouge le fou en
profil et aussi il empêche par les C5
parce qu'il y aura toujours un petit
coup franc
si jamais tu pousses le pion Caballé
aussi donc là il donne le la part de fou
qui ce qui a notre plutôt dans un
terrain ici des des Noirs tu vois qu'il
a peur de vous maintenant posez là avoue
que je suis assez sceptique de ce qui a
été proposé par le cache
je t'as l'impression que c'est un jeu un
peu timide s'il était pas 25 j'ai
l'impression qu'il a empilé si tu veux
des coups mais qu'il a pas progressé au
contraire c'est il fait des concessions
si tu veux donc
OK
très jolie l'idée on prend on va changer
la structure et on va récupérer le
cavalier en fait en C3 et d'ailleurs ça
c'est la partie on va l'avoir un petit
peu après et
sur pion prend c'est ça et sur cavalier
prend ben j'aurais faut prendre F1
intermédiaire joli et ensuite manger là
en fait ça permet d'échanger les pièces
et de changer de la structure parce que
là du coup je suis quand même deux fois
dessus complètement à pied le jeu si
vous voulez quand on gagne le footcas
noir de l'adversaire c'est le jeu de
couleur c'est de jouer sur casse noire
donc voilà c'est exactement ce qui est
en train de se passer avec ce cavalier
C5 les Noirs veulent l'ouvrir la
position sur case noir et les Noirs
réussissent d'ailleurs ce tour de force
avec un DIN qui va jouer pour gagner
avec les noirs
après qui apparemment aura un avantage
là c'est net selon l'ordi on vous
expliquera si c'est net on ne le dira on
va aller voir
donc ça ça garde ce fou on garde les
cases noires encore une fois on a la
paire de fou hein le la concession qui a
fait ici Lucas avec fupron F6 maintenant
on commence un peu à s'en ressentir au
niveau des cases noires
[Musique]
sur les cases noires donc c'est une
bonne chose d'un côté parce que ça prend
quand même pas mal de cases aussi la
colonne C qui maintenant est fermée
grâce au vous cette fois mais d'un autre
côté le fou qui est un peu enfermé qui
est pas très actif
donc
elle est super pour les Noirs mais
je suis en train de calculer eux prend
des cartes tout simplement
pour voir le problème sur le fousset 3
et le pion C6 apparaître alors il est
instrument quelque chose qui a été prévu
par dingeren mais
ce coup fait quand même assez sens et ce
qu'on peut aller justement bêtement
prononcer 6 ou simplement tour C8 nous
condamne à donner du matériel je pensais
à me voler je suis revenu en fait
je voulais prendre du fou moi souffre
pour garder justement un œil mais
peut-être que ça marche quand même
mais c'est moins clair c'est pour ça que
je parlais de tour C8 éventuellement qui
a un coût mais il y aurait peut-être
vous prend 8 faut vérifier elle était
beaucoup plus autant d'un Français 6
comme tu le disais on voyait les
prises des trois prises F2 faire mal
autant là c'est un petit peu différent
c'est pas si facile avec les noirs de
prouver même si on sent que c'est bien
sous fait que se fout des cartes
monstrueux et c'est ça on prend des
trois ouais tout à fait mais je prends
de la tour
ce que tu as toujours eu sera en l'air
donc vous prenez F2 d'un point F2
malheureusement
ta tour 8 en l'air donc finalement ça
inverse le résultat
du coup prenez trois peut-être là de
suite c'est pas le bon coup mais on sent
que tu es pas loin de la vérité c'est
tout mais je n'arrive pas à trouver si
tu veux vraiment le le gain noir ou la
prise d'avantage noire ou peut-être
juste on joue aux échecs dans cette
position si c'est pas impossible c'est à
dire que on pourrait continuer le
travail
dans ce cas là quelques jouets
pas simple parce que je peux compter
chaque je fais ça tu bouges ton fou et
peut-être je fais ça
si vous voulez là
ça marche ça marche oui l'idée de ça sur
un point en fait ce qui se passe le
problème c'est qu'il va y avoir échec et
surtout reprend la langue et encore et
encore il y a toujours C8 je crois bah
là je pourrais revenir en fait mais
en fait j'avais ma tour en D1
donc je suis même pas sûr sauf en fait
que ça marche ou quand même de juste ou
alors j'hallucinais peut-être mais d'un
me prendre des trois fois F2 genre
incroyable
et l'autre tour qui va manger derrière
c'était rayons X donc ouais
pas si simple
elle est compliquée en position parce
que on sent le fou noir est fort mais
vous voyez c'est un pion donné quand
même par dingleren c'est pour ça que ça
me paraissait pas si simple c'est que
oui
tu gardes un super pro je crois mais
après pour voir si j'ai pas des trucs
mais
voyez on a un pion de moins de
contraintes mais pour l'instant c'est la
paire de fou qui s'exprime avec le beau
fou des cas là et du coup je trouve des
coups simplement pour stabiliser et
montrer que le jeu de pièces suffit à
compenser le pion de moi parce qu'un
jour je vais réussir à récupérer
peut-être il y a tactiquement en fait
pas trop de problèmes quoi
cette partie je préfère largement la
position de floue
mais il y a encore beaucoup de travail
en tout cas digneren très fort déjà ce
qui montre
du coup la partie caméra c'est la partie
pour les noirs
et sur 5 tours BM ok donc il va pousser
les quatre ce qui est hyper thématique
il y a eu du coup A4 qui empêche
B4 parce qu'attention si le joue mégat
ici et ben il y a le cou qu'on oublie
tous un peu souvent c'est apprendre BK
avec prise en passant alors non mais la
présentation c'est encore une fois hier
j'avais un cours et j'ai un élève qui
m'a demandé comment ça marchait non mais
j'avais du mal moi quand j'étais plus
petit en plus
qu'on oublie tous ça m'a fait quand même
marrer non pas toi tu n'oublies pas mais
en fait
euh débutant on y pense pas en fait ce
soir du coup bah ça arrive pas souvent
en fait en vérité ça n'arrive pas
souvent je pense encore moins niveau
débutant en plus ça alors on va on va
vous expliquer un petit peu juste si
jamais il y a dans le chat si vous avez
des doutes là-dessus hein
B4 en fait si on a enfin si on place un
pion à côté deuxième puis on va dire
j'avance de deux cases vous voyez et
quand j'avance de case je suis
exactement à côté d'un point noir à ce
moment-là les pions noirs pourra venir
manger mon pion voilà vraiment que mon
pion fasse deux coups
de cases à la fois qu'on soit à côté et
on pourra manger seulement à ce tour de
jeu par exemple sur B4 si il fait un
coup je ne pourrais plus maintenant
voyez moi j'en mets trois ça marche plus
quand le pion avance de deux cases qu'il
passe par la première case donc on peut
le prendre à ce moment là à ce tour de
jeu c'est ça du coup c'est que à ce
moment-là c'est pas obligatoire c'est
pas
mais du coup bah là c'est de le faire
parce que du coup ça fait ça
ici est un mauvais coup alors pour ça
que à 4 est bien joué parce qu'en fait
on sait que B4 c'est pas bien joué et du
coup on bloque un petit peu la case et
on bloque à pousser P4 donc grâce à 4 on
bloque un peu toute cette ce côté-là
d'échiquier
bonne année RCK donc
nous en technique enfin surtout que moi
et il a voulu mettre salut et il a mis
alu est-ce que tu penses qu'il a fait
exprès ou que c'est juste une faute de
frappe ça me paraît un peu étonnant le
alu bonne année mais je pense que c'est
une faute de frappe
c'est possible pas volontaire je pense
que c'est pas volontaire c'est possible
du coup
ok V4
[Musique]
c'est 5 c'est intéressant que se
passe-t-il faut prendre le sac en fait
il veut juste et magnifique c'est
intéressant le plan des blancs
clairement ça va être d'enlever les
pièces noires qui défendent le pion à 5
afin de aller manger
ça va être cavalier français 6 et sur
plein de processus de manger en E5 donc
de quelle pierre tombante la tour ou du
cavalier moi j'aime bien le cavalier
perso mais le réveil du fougé deux hein
on vous l'avez déjà exprimé quand vous
avez un flou comme ça il faut le
réveiller et là il est en train de se
réveiller fort c'est ça
du coup du coup voilà il va éliminer les
deux défenseurs du temps à 5 grâce à
Caval et B4 et assez simple là vous
voyez que le cavalier B4 il était pas
trop probable non plus à cause
excusez-moi encore buggé
à cause je le refais
de
prendre et 5
voilà c'est compliqué parce que l'option
des cartes devient isolé vers toute
seule c'est une grosse faiblesse etc
donc ça veut pas faire des noirs
est magnifique mais la concession que
les Blancs ont réalisé c'est de donner
le centre du coup on voit que tous les
coups que nous proposent tous c'est pour
montrer que le centre noir va voler en
éclat c'est ce que MacDo SLU makzlou
voulait prouver dans le début mais il
n'a pas réussi visiblement
donc LBK donc on va tout ce qui fait ça
a du sens les pions sont trop en plus de
valeur que des pions de l'aile
généralement
donc C5 donc là maintenant il vient
contrôler
il va venir manger ce fou ça c'est bien
vu de la part des Noirs
je crois
[Musique]
comment je
ça serait assez logique de tout croquer
en C6 pour venir défendre
[Musique]
position difficile j'ai l'impression
pour
les pièces blanches qui au final n'ont
pas de bonne case peut-être qu'elle va
le car tu as changé des pièces tout ça
mais au final vous voyez que le pion B2
ça tourne une faiblesse avec la 3 B2
sauf que finalement l'avantage noir
central perdure que Max doudou il a pas
réussi à faire à faire la différence il
a attaqué les centres avec ces petites
manœuvres ça n'a pas ça n'a pas avancé
et pour répondre à manutention voilà la
règle avantage centrale suffit à donner
un bel avantage puisque sauf nous a
expliqué que finalement pion A4 vaut
quasiment B2 et A3 il reste
structurellement la position elle ne va
pas et en fait structure réactivité ça
ne va pas ce sont deux gros critères de
stratégie il reste le rapport matériel
qui est égal et le roi blanc même s'il
est un peu moins bien il est pas en
danger non plus mais rien qu'activité
structure c'est beaucoup c'est pour ça
qu'il y a à peu près un pion d'avance
virtuel pour les Noirs à cause de cette
meilleure structure et de sa meilleure
activité
mes parents tristes très clairement il
est pas bien
voilà et c'est vrai que le bonus
il est venu
peut-être sans prépa sans pression aussi
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas hyper
impressionnant ce qui vient de nous
montrer avec les Blancs après c'est un
joueur a plus de 2700
peut-être que sur cette partie il était
pas très inspiré
yes donc elles participent pas
l'événement malheureusement non il n'est
pas là on n'a pas vraiment de raison
c'est pas s'il a été invité ou pas ou
s'il a juste refusé
mais en tout cas je vais pas partir de
joueurs présents dans cet événement
c'est dommage sinon on serait à fond sur
Maxime mais
voilà d'autant plus dommage qu'il aurait
largement le niveau évidemment mais
comme on l'a expliqué c'est pas facile
de se payer un chemin rien que pour être
invité alors faudrait voir il a
peut-être été mais toujours est-il que
on voit qu'il y a des jeunes pépites
comme Vincent Kemer on a cité goukaish
on a cité regaizi on a cité pragnananda
abdosa torov donc ça c'est tous les
pépites et après il y a les vieux
routards dont frais parti mvl avec Arsen
à rognan carwana guéri Ding wesleo mais
en fait pour mettre un VL il faudrait
vraiment virer entre guillemets un grand
nombre de échecs il y a que Max doudou
ça participe passion elle est un peu
plus étonnante mais on l'a dit en début
de stream il remplace Yann Christophe
Douda donc finalement par rapport à tous
les noms qu'on a cité et notre MV c'est
pas clair quand même les autres les
autres noms qu'on a cité c'est des
monstres du jeu d'échec quoi donc
finalement ça s'explique aussi et du
coup je pense que Maxime est dans une
une période où voilà où ça sourit pas
trop niveau du jeu et je pense que s'il
avait été invité ben il aurait eu envie
de défendre ses choix parce qu'il doit
regagner des points il doit faire plus
mal que c'est récentes se performance et
c'est toujours la quête et en plus voilà
il atteint un âge ou maintenant il est
il voit des jeunes pousses à rivés donc
il doit il doit prouver tous les jours
c'est pas facile
le Wim le donne des échecs c'est assez
marrant de le dire comme ça font tout
noir
c'est pas mal j'aime bien on a reçu tu
n'as pas reçu le mail de James comme toi
c'est pas forcément de Fontenoy c'est
mignon
c'est bien mais avec le gazon en moins
c'est ça il y a pas de gazon là c'est
qui qui est à l'origine de l'article
c'est Sami ou c'est
pas moi je l'ai reçu je l'ai ouvert et
puis je la refais
je pense que je l'ai dans
alors du coup pendant ce temps-là je
vais voir si on a d'autres parties
intéressantes alors
[Musique]
c'est intéressant on voit le cavalier
noir qui est venu en D8 en un peu ce qui
s'est passé on s'est arrêté à fond 4
je l'avais pas vu j'étais étonné ouais
mais il a été envoyé c'était en fait le
Wim me le donne des échecs c'était
pendant notre stream tu as 14h03
j'ai pas le droit à l'erreur parce que
ça me disait rien l'histoire ouais
d'accord donc du coup
je comprends mieux
donc il y a eu tout rêve 7 tiens il a il
a pas accepté à l'entrée de la tour en
C7 c'est la fête pour reculer un petit
peu et après d'arme 3 d'ailleurs est-ce
que vous entendez un petit peu les
travaux chez moi parce que j'ai bon
c'est nickel c'est beaucoup moins moins
fort qu'avant et j'ai aussi
fait un truc sur Obs pour enlever le
bruit mais je suis pas sûr donc juste
jamais il y a du bruit il y a pas de
bruit
merveilleuse que tu arrives à nous faire
tellement
ça serait bien d'ailleurs que tu mettes
pas la barre trop haut parce que tu
comprends après mon mon désarroi face à
ce qui m'attend et face à cette épreuve
tu auras pas de bruit je pense chez toi
il y a pas de souci quoi non normalement
ça ira rappelle-toi que je serai là
quand même dimanche
[Musique]
permet d'être
de me faire progresser évidemment ça
sera pédagogique
c'est juste pédagogique
donc pour celui qui tourner 6 proposés
par Sky Sky mobile je suis plus Torcé
vite parce que ton vesti je pense qu'il
y a cavaler B7 et il y a toujours aussi
non
c'est hyper embêtant quand même
parce que tous ces 8 tours F8 ça va
et tours c'est ça ton répète et tour des
6 je sais pas trop quoi jouer en fait
donc j'ai pas vu en prise donc encore
une fois j'ai blender
50 + 10 ouais mais je crois on n'a pas
le droit de jouer en 50 plus il se fait
ainsi on peut jouer mais vous voyez ce
que je veux dire on gagne pas les points
qu'on ait plus de 22 je crois ça ça a
changé parce que alors je sais pas à
l'époque il y a plein de toi moins de
2002 et maintenant ils ont eu plein de
temps à moins de 2004
je sais pas ce que c'est comme cadence
moi j'en ai plus encore mais
tu fais ton petit 50 + 10 tu prends 20
points à l'eau sauf bam ça deux fois et
c'est cool quoi
sur le plan le plan
ises un petit 50 plus 10 au Canaries
juste avant de partir tu piques les
points des locaux Pamiers
tu sais c'est il y a quelques heures à
2002 super ça tu les invites le tournoi
des copains
petit hello par rapport à toi ou plutôt
le performeur qu'on les gros hello non
généralement je suis bon ça dépend des
moments mais généralement je suis assez
bon pour que je vois moins fort
ok
donc j'ai eu de très bons scores par
exemple là j'ai fait des normes enfin
j'ai cinq normes de mètres mais parmi
mes cinq normes de mètres j'en ai fait
deux en N1 et mes deux scores ont un an
ça a été du
genre il avait eu j'ai fait du
j'avais 7 sur 8
on risquait pas mal
et j'ai fait beaucoup en fait de score
comme ça mais dès que je joue du genre à
2005 plus fort et ben j'ai plus de mal
et donc je peux les battre mais on va
dire que je suis pas le joueur qui est
vraiment solide qui va faire nul qui va
essayer de comprendre puis le joueur qui
qui balance plus et qui blender plus et
qui
et puis la grand-mère sont stables donc
c'est pas facile de les secouer de les
avoir jusqu'au bout quoi
donc bon bah après moi j'aime beaucoup
je compte les fois en fait ça me motive
plus mais bien sûr
beaucoup moins moins bon mais oui un
petit 2002 2003 je suis plus
mon score sera meilleur
tu vois donc dans le chat ils ont été
hyper bon
c'est moins 2004 maintenant c'est le 1h
+ 30 secondes une heure
ça peut être en vrai c'est des cadences
vraiment qui me
[Musique]
correspond bien parce que moi je suis
tout très vite je réfléchis pas quoi et
du coup je mets l'impression un petit
peu en rejoint au hasard quoi et du coup
bah bon ça passe ça casse mais dans les
cadences comme ça souvent ça fait un peu
bluff tu vois et c'est intéressant
par jour en moyenne
voilà plus rien moi au travail
[Musique]
à la maison enfin nous notre travail
parce qu'on travaille dans les échecs si
moi je suis à peu près à zéro
donc quand je suis retournant par contre
je me préparais je vais je vais pas mal
me préparer faire des tactiques faire
des trucs par contre hors compétition je
suis à zéro pendant je travaille pas
quoi ça tu fais toute la journée tu fais
des cours d'échecs des trucs etc des
streams
de ta journée tu as pas envie de
d'ouvrir cheesebab de faire un truc
enfin non tu moi après la journée tu vas
voir une série qui a rien à voir avec
les échecs tu vois tu fais un truc tu
fais tu veux sortir de ta bulle en fait
genre le jeu de la dame quoi tu sais tu
vas te faire
changer les idées mais
tu peux être passionné et tout mais
quand je travaille beaucoup enfin je
pense quand c'est ton boulot tu as du
mal derrière à vraiment tu vois après
moi c'est pas mon boulot de Joseph par
exemple si tu prends un grand maître qui
qui vide ça tu vois par exemple tu es là
on parle avec Mathieu dans le chat
Mathieu il est il est entraîneur tout ça
mais il est aussi avant tout genre
d'échec quoi et son travail quoi enfin
il est grand maître il est professionnel
bien sûr donc je pense que lui il
travaille en tout cas bon après lui
c'est un curieux il va regarder un peu
toujours des lignes tout ça mais
moi je suis pas genre d'échec enfin je
vis pas de je vais pas de ça quoi
je serai sous un pont quoi et puis
c'est les choix autre aussi bon après
c'est aussi par exemple un joueur comme
Mathieu on l'a déjà dit il était à titre
perso on a été beaucoup dans la même
catégorie il y a toujours eu les 100 150
points d'écart qui ont fait que lui
c'était légitime qui passe grand maître
assez tôt qui veuille faire pro et
malgré son super niveau le fait d'être
champion de France etc il est très
difficile de vivre que de jouer aux
échecs il faut être extrêmement
extrêmement fort si on fait partie de
l'élite mondiale on peut très bien
gagner sa vie mais c'est vraiment
extrêmement marginal même les meilleurs
joueurs nationaux tous ne gagne pas leur
vie ou en tout cas sont obligés de faire
d'autres choses autour des échecs comme
tu le dis les cours les commentaires les
livres etc en tout cas de ce
démultiplier ce qui n'est pas très bon
pour la carrière de joueur
c'est ça nous jouez d'ailleurs enfin à
titre perso joue quasiment plus et se
trouve un peu donc vous voyez c'est pas
un bon calcul si on veut progresser aux
échecs
[Musique]
ils se démultiplient lui aussi parce que
on va dire qu'il y a une bonne barre des
26-50 27 maintenant qui qui est plus
intéressantes et même même à ce niveau
là 26 50 27 il y en a encore qui sont
secondants
on connaît l'exemple de Laurent
Frayssinet au niveau de Magnus Carson
etc etc donc
c'est dur et puis même quand vous prenez
de l'âge aux échecs c'est pas aussi
difficile qu'un sportif qui doit arrêter
on va dire à 35 ans en règle générale en
moyenne il y a des contre-exemples mais
là on va pouvoir pousser à 45 50 mais
après on voit à Nantes on voit cramique
qui était présent
Topalov je sais pas où il est voilà
ils peuvent pas rester au niveau de la
ligne mondial voir les petits jeunes
arrivés et être en freestyle total non
faut être tout le temps au taquet et il
y a une sorte d'usure par rapport à la
discipline de fatigue mentale et aussi
d'énergie tout simplement initiale pour
tenir c'est dur à
oui non mais c'est clair hein
je pense que je pense pas
je pense pas non mais ouais c'est clair
moi je pense que Mbappe et il gagne plus
que tous les joueurs d'échec réunis
après bon il y a peut-être dans dans les
joueurs d'échec quelques quelques
rentiers qui peuvent augmenter qui
peuvent contrebalancer
ce que je viens de dire mais
après pas facile
non mais ok on n'est pas le même monde
quoi pendant le même monde c'est vrai
que du coup ben pour l'échec c'est quand
même plus dur il faut que tu sois
vraiment très très fort pour vraiment
bien en vivre en tant que joueur même au
tennis finalement il y a que l'élite qui
s'en sort hyper bien apparemment c'est
quand même difficile ou alors il faut
faire comme nous c'est à dire donner des
cours etc c'est ça mais après même quand
tu vois le challenger de ce tournoi là
bah je pense que la plainte
après je sais pas je me rends pas compte
pour tabac Tabe il est pro à 10 bandes
pro l'ami les pro supplie je pense qu'il
est pro Yilmaz je pense qu'il est
provitch je pense qu'il est pro
il a 13 ans maintenant il a 25 60
[Musique]
on peut dire aussi c'est que il y a
certains pros qui sont plus faibles à 24
24 50 25 qui font on va dire 6 mois hors
de leur pays au niveau de vie et
relativement faible
et le collecte
de l'argent en gagnant des tournois en
faisant des performances dans des plus
petits tournois des tournois plus
confidentiels et il rentre au pays et le
niveau de vie étant plus faible mais ils
vivent très bien chez eux mais c'est une
vie qu'on ne peut pas nécessairement
envier c'est quand même c'est quand même
dur comme vie et puis il y a toujours la
limite de l'âge à un moment
cette course à l'argent
en fait en fait ouais mais bon quand tu
es pro il faut en vivre quoi c'est quand
même un métier quoi dire c'est un métier
en fait donc
oui oui et puis ouais vulgaire si tu
parles d'emba oui mais de nous ça va on
reste assez non voilà mais mais à un
moment donné quand tu es pro et que tu
fais des échecs il faut aller où il y a
de l'argent quoi c'est ton métier quoi
après après oui on se compare le foot
avec tout ça
pour moi c'est quand même un métier
enfin pour nous c'est pas un métier pour
moi c'est pas un métier mais quand tu
t'appelles
[Musique]
c'est quand même ton métier quoi
parce que je pense que tu parles de du
jeu d'échec d'être joueur pro aux échecs
je pense pas qu'elle joueur de foot dans
ce cas là c'est plus un métier que je
vois d'échec enfin très clairement même
en termes de charge de travail la charge
de travail est très très lourde je pense
que c'est tout à fait comparable voire
plus dur que des hautes études faudrait
comparer c'est difficile
mais je trouve que c'est que c'est
extrêmement difficile faut être très
complet pour être joueur d'échec et
ouais et ça se rendre à avoir des
connaissances encyclopédique et merci
karaï pour pour le petit mot sur la
plate ça fait bien plaisir si ça plaît
mais en tout cas oui c'est bizarre c'est
un jeu qui parfois est rémunéré et après
comme dans n'importe quelle discipline
il y a des gens qui gravitent autour et
il y a des entraîneurs pro et il y a
aussi et ça il faut pas le casser dans
les associations des bénévoles ça je
l'entends bien c'est peut-être ton
postulat et ça ça me paraît pas
en fait c'est un jeu pour les gens qui
sont qui sont pas enfin moi je pense
c'est un jeu pour les gens qui sont pas
vraiment dans le monde des échecs parce
que ok tu peux te dire oui c'est un
hobby c'est un passe-temps c'est un jeu
c'est un truc que c'est le dimanche
voilà mais en fait
pour les meilleurs joueurs c'est pas du
tout un jeu quoi enfin ça reste un jeu
mais c'est un métier et c'est leur vie
qui dédié à ça donc
en fait
tu vois quand tu quand tu vois les
championnats du monde tout ça voilà
c'est des gens qui détenus carrière à ça
donc pour cette personne là c'est pas un
jeu enfin c'est plus qu'un jeu tu vois
ce que je veux dire
bien fait marrer il m'a dit moi c'est
l'inverse je perds de l'argent et je
fais pour jouer bah tu es passionné
c'est ça rejoint je pense que tout ça se
recoupe un petit peu et du coup c'est
exactement ça ça peut être voilà c'est
comme n'importe quel sport et ben il y
en a qui voient ça comme un jeu moi je
fais du volet pendant quelques années
j'adore ce sport bah pour moi c'est un
passe-temps je suis je suis nul je
m'amuse et puis voilà mais c'est pas
encore ta carrière de volleyeur souffre
ça m'intéresse je peux dire que je suis
tout ouïe non mais tu vois je vais
jamais te dire que tu vois il y a des
gens qui sont pro et comme dans tous les
sports c'est tout
je dois pas comme un sport pour moi pas
comme un sport si tu as pas comme un
comme un métier pour moi ni rien parce
que moi je joue pour m'amuser tu vois si
on y tiens vas-y je te donne l'argent
pour aller faire un match de tennis de
truc bon moi je suis nul je vais mais tu
vois l'idée c'est que ça me traverse pas
de la dans la tête de vraiment tout
faire pour gagner de l'argent en
j'envoyais sachant que mon niveau il est
très bas et que je veux je m'amuser quoi
ta vie ta carrière à un sport dans
lequel tu es fort
et Ben
et ben c'est différent tu vois tu es
différent là pour le coup
c'est des heures de travail c'est pas
comparable moi je me retrouve
complètement dans ce que tu dis je fais
du badminton du foot bah voilà je fais
ça en tant que passionné mais à un
niveau extrêmement moindre que le reste
quoi c'est effectivement un passe-temps
ça peut être oui c'est un sport mais ça
reste du jeu voilà il y a pas d'attente
sur le côté compétitif
sur le résultat et des moyens mis en
oeuvre autour pour je sais pas de la
musculation le matin stouf franchement
je devrais pour en vue de mes matchs de
foot quoi enfin voilà c'est très très
dur
ok bon du coup là j'ai mis la potion de
Caravana contre Guiri qui est un peu en
stand by par rapport à tout à l'heure
avec le pion le pion en C5 qui est qui
est visé et il y a aussi toi le pur en
détroit qui est qui est visible de
l'autre côté peut-être un tour 5 qui
peut arriver un jour et taper sur
Detroit et bien sûr la classe de 4 qui
est toujours qui est toujours
d'actualité tu vois les Noirs vraiment
c'est de bloquer au maximum
c'était plus en arrière en Détroit et
empêche un peu la la poussée tu vois si
c'était chaud il y a pas longtemps qui
empêche du coup des quatre avec souper
et du coup pendant ce temps là on va
réussir peut-être à mettre la pression
d'ailleurs sur le pion sur le pion de 3
guérir pour l'instant qui fait une
partie très propre
et on va voir un petit peu
s'il arrive à prendre l'avantage du coup
sur
carbonara mais guérisse le tournoi alors
on l'a dit par rapport au palmarès du
tournoi guéri n'a jamais gagné ton nom
mais il a fait 5 fois 2e
et donc quand même toujours toujours
dans le tableau donc ce serait pas une
surprise
il y a quand même Carlsen donc Carlson
qui l'a gagné X fois ça ça c'est
bloquant très clairement il aide pas
il est pas oui je pense qu'elle forcer
non mais bon le jeu c'est pas ça là ça
d'accord non mais après en fait faut
avoir la discussion
faudra en discuter de vive voix et voilà
après on joue peut-être sur les mots en
pensant quasiment la même chose
oui non bien sûr mais après
clairement car Wana s'est trompé dans
l'ouverture par contre guéri fait un peu
peur au niveau de sa gestion du temps sa
position semble assez facile à jouer
naturellement et il prend quand même
quelques longueurs en termes de temps
faudrait pas que ça lui porte préjudice
en même temps il doit s'apercevoir qu'il
est mieux et il a pas envie de de
laisser car wanna revenir complètement
dans la partie voilà
que ils ont pas là ils ont pas la jauge
les joueurs
donc je vous ai mis sur le sur le stream
les le tableau des tournois des
participants avec les appareils qui sont
en direct donc vous avez 20 forest qui
joue ce rapport qui joue Nord bec
abdoslo contre gamer on a
45 contre aronyan et on a Prague contre
irigasi
j'aimerais bien qu'on aille revoir
Richard rapporte contre adoussa torov si
tu es d'accord sauf ça fait un moment
qu'on n'est pas allé voir c'est vrai que
c'est une partie qui était assez
intéressante avec le roi qui est parti
en bien très vite on va revenir à ce
moment-là il y a eu quatre échec c'était
le gros bazar
donc ça on s'est arrêté à tomber tout à
fait du coup Abdou qui a fait quand même
il dit moi je m'en fous
il a une deuxième pièce sur le rock noir
puisqu'il y a tourbé un FF3 qui sont
actives maintenant cette pièce là c'est
ça
donc F3 il y a eu 7
cavaillage 3
F4 tout à fait
B6
pour empêcher cavalier 4 je pense
que maintenant cavalier F4 il y a
peut-être cavalier prend E5 stuff
c'est assez compliqué tout ça mais qui
avait 5 possibilités avec la dame qui
défend plus le pion peut-être sur des
découvertes voilà auparavant il y avait
l'air là il est plus en l'air mais les
deux rois
qui sont quand même sous pression tu
vois que le roi noir et les cannes sous
pression avec tous les vis-à-vis qui
arrivent et le roi blanc qui est dévoqué
complètement ici donc
pas la position des fois ça peut arriver
un tout petit lag
et du coup d'accord
premier merci en tout cas
il a repris la perceuse je pensais que
c'était un petit marteau ah mais tu
entends
non non j'ai entendu
si vous entendez moi je coupe un mec
dites moi juste après
sinon je t'aurais dit mais là pas du
tout enfin c'est ça peut arriver un
petit peu en tout cas
et si vous l'entendez maintenant un très
peu
parce que
j'étais réveillé ce matin avec ça quoi
donc déjà de bonne humeur au réveil et
ça n'arrête pas
entendu c'est pour la première fois donc
mais peut-être que c'est pas gênant je
pense que ça fait le charme de ce de ce
stream
il y a toujours un problème de toute
façon il y a toujours un truc
dis-moi est-ce que le stream est
sponsorisé par Castorama et d'ailleurs
peut-être qu'au Canaries tu as une
marque un peu comme Castorama donc tu
voudrais nous faire part
non le magasin de bricolage parce que la
dernière fois tu m'avais un peu étonné
avec ton supermarché alors et du coup tu
as peut-être une marque alors je suis
allé à les Roy merlim tu connais
le roy Merlin là ça me dit quelque chose
là samedi quelque chose parce que ma
copine et puis on allait faire un
magasin enfin tu as acheté des trucs et
moi je dis mais le roy Merlin qu'est-ce
qu'il me dit en fait c'est Leroy Merlin
tu vois ça c'est vraiment mon accent
quoi en fait tu vois je comprenais pas
Leroy Merlin quoi et en fait le roy
Merlin qu'est-ce qui me raconte et elle
me dit mais tu connais pas c'est connu
mais je dis bébé genre c'est français
quoi et mais bon on aura eu marine quoi
et donc voilà donc je suis allé au
romarin en tout cas j'ai bien aimé la
remarque de citadelo il propose une
solution il aime bien les bricoleurs
mais propose une solution assez radicale
il dit appelle les flics pour pour qu'il
fait du bruit
non mais en fait
il me semble que c'est que en vrai que
le dimanche non tu as le droit de faire
ça
le dimanche le dimanche par exemple tu
fais tes déchets verts tondeuse et
compagnie que le matin quoi on est un
peu au-delà du tata style là mais en
tout cas en tout cas ouais ouais pour
moi
le dimanche c'est pas le droit le
dimanche le dimanche maintenant tu ça
dépend de la commune ouais mdal tu es
pas mal tapage viande existe vous êtes
vous êtes pas mal dans le chat on a
réussi à réveiller le chat avec avec des
petites discussions bricolage je pense
que nous on n'est pas au niveau du chat
au niveau du bricolage
du monde ça m'aurait évité des
conseillers pour la moustiquaire
tout ça pourquoi au bout du compte tu
fasses en achat qui dont tu ne te sers
pas
il veut me faire chier depuis qui c'est
que je parle et tout voilà
d'accord
c'est un peu ça
vas-y pétrole je t'attends j'attends ta
carte
du coup qui est joué c'est un coup qui
est là bizarre mais j'imagine qu'il veut
bon déjà il veut défendre les cavaliers
et peut-être essayer de se replacer
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un coup alors
je sais pas mais du style C6 aussi parce
que au final c'est vrai que les Blancs
menacent des fois du Fou des cinq tours
de 5e
peuvent un jour être un petit peu
ennuyant après cette liste c'est un coup
quand même qui affaiblit le roi et qui
bloque le Caval mais
moi je commence à en fait je sens que la
position des des blancs elle va pas
parce que
ton roi il est une vidéo
à un moment donné ils vont venir
paraître dominé par les pions etc le
pion S1 qui risque de tomber un jour tu
as l'impression que c'est une potion qui
va pas trop pour les blancs mais je sais
pas pourquoi mais j'aime bien les blancs
ah ouais d'accord parce que moi j'ai un
problème je trouve que le coup cab8 a
glissoire de C6
dont tu viens de parler c'est énorme
parce que fou design dames G6 je pense
et après c'est 6 arrivent donc c'est pas
jouable faut des cinq je crois
alors sinon il y avait foot des cinq dam
F3 très intéressant donc le
commence à être j'ai du mal à trouver
des objectifs si tu veux et à savoir
comment les réaliser aussi parce que
trouver des objectifs matelas noir c'est
un bel objectif mais c'est pas
réalisable
incapa 5 c'est rien du tout j'attaque
avec une pièce qu'est-ce que je fais de
se fout c'est un j'ai du mal à
travailler les cases blanches à cause de
ce cahier B8 monstrueux je trouve sauf
très très joli coup mais je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord parce que là
on va rester à fermer la porte et une
fois que la tour sera parti peut-être
s'occuper aussi du du pion en E5
possible faut prendre le 5 armes
attention aux cloche ça c'est genre de
choses qu'il faut essayer d'éviter
et quand tu calcules ça il faut vraiment
vraiment faire attention parce que
il y a peut-être fou des cinq après donc
c'est chaud un petit peu il va falloir
claquer la tour peut-être il faut
vraiment
mais juste moi je n'ai pas calculé parce
que ça m'avait l'air bizarre mais en
calculant on va savoir si tout j'ai eu
de gagne la pièce ou pas où est-ce que
foudre
[Musique]
Arnaud tu vois tu tu alignes
parce que j'aurais dit ça ça ou alors ou
alors tu bouges ta dame aussi et tu fais
tu reprends j'ai vite remarques non mais
je fais ces 6 d'abord
parce que je l'ai vu après en fait pour
te dire
et
là je peux faire soit Dame des 7 soit tu
reprends des 5 je sais pas un des deux
si on prend et d'un B5
vous voyez j'ai ça en prise et ça en
prime
c'est pas forcément gagné
mais ce qui est particulièrement chaud
c'est qu'il y a double alignement là
vous avez vu la séquence est sympa avec
sauf celle que il vous a mis t'étais
rigolo comme tout
elle est chaude cette partie c'est tout
hein
en fait c'est dur quand même avec les
blancs de savoir ce qu'on va faire en
fait peut-être H4 non je sais pas quoi
jouer avec les Blancs
que tu as des idées toi parce que moi je
suis parti c'est une partie compliquée
où là les blancs sont en train de
Caroline parce que
[Musique]
la pollution comme je t'ai dit et je
pense que dans le fond elle est mauvaise
pour les blancs parce que j'ai pas le
centre ce plan il va tomber je vais
virer la tour je vais virer tes fous et
le roi blanc je pense que une fois la
poste sera ouverte ce sera plus faible
que le roi noir sur le sur le long terme
tu as l'impression vraiment que qu'il y
a un problème chez les Blancs et du coup
les blancs
doivent être un petit peu en mustwin toi
en ligne quoi parce que tu peux pas
jouer normalement enfin c'est pas une
partie normale si tu veux tu vois sur le
long terme le blé blanc sont très mal et
je pense qu'ils doivent essayer de
réagir et trouver quelque chose
donc
donc voilà je sais pas comment comment
jouer pour un sac ne marche pas
tourin tu vois il préfère un truc mais
tu as l'impression que tous les attaques
comme ça ça va amener nulle part
et que c'est très très dur à trouver
pour les blancs et que chaque coup les
blancs peuvent faire on va dire des
imprécisions ou des erreurs ils peuvent
qui peuvent leur coûter la partie parce
que nous on peut proposer des coups et
tout mais un coup comme un théâtre par
exemple ça peut être ça que
en plus c'est assez neutre en terme
d'apport si tu veux tout faire c'est
pour ça que je sais pas comment cerner
la position je manque d'idées je peux
jouer tout au loin je peux jouer des
coups de consolidation mais on voit que
les Noirs vont améliorer celle-ci
sachant etc ça fait peur
très gêné pour jouer cette position et
je suis d'accord je n'aime pas les
blancs non plus si tu as des lots et
crusti déçu de pas avoir de pas avoir de
grands bidame accepté mais tu as quand
même la partie je t'invite à regarder
car washiri guéri et
c'est presque un gambida max accepté en
termes de formation de pièces dans le
début alors bien sûr tu vois les pions
Détroit et D4 qui sont en trompe l'oeil
mais finalement c'était un début rétique
s'est transformé en presque gambidamax
accepté il y a des quatre mais la
formation employée par les Noirs dans
cette partie par guérisse et typiquement
le gambidam accepté
donc là il a finalement mis un des
quatre et là du coup le pur est en
prison on peut imaginer comme ça qu'ici
ou pas
en tout cas c'est quand même guéri il
joue au carwana avec les Noirs il est en
train de partir il roule dessus en terme
de stratégie ça va quoi ça va
là il lui roule dessus même au speed
chasse j'avais bien aimé sa façon de
jouer enfin il joue extrêmement bien
ouais ouais c'est ça il joue très propre
un peu dans le style de Manu je trouve
un peu sous côté le guéri non pas par
son hello mais par oui il est pas pas
souvent cité et je trouve que c'est un
joueur quand même qui a une une classe
assez extraordinaire
alors peut-être qu'il est un peu plus
lisse comme personnage je sais pas
ça c'est autre chose et si fini toujours
deuxième
c'est toujours un petit peu un petit peu
ça aussi il faut gagner pour avoir le
droit de
chanter
alors du coup est-ce que tu joues 5 ou
pas
si tu nous demandes une partie du B on
peut aller voir on ira peut-être faire
un petit tour mais plutôt par
ouais voilà par demande un petit peu
peut-être on ira voir la petite pépite
la petite pépite on nous a parlé
c'est
un petit grand
le plus jeune grand maître de tous les
temps d'ailleurs
quand même pas rien peut-être je trouve
concernant ce 5 je joue souvent en
partie en partie assez rapide si je peux
peut-être attendre pour laisser mon fous
circuler genre foi F6 c'est pas donné
l'info si je joue au 5 ou pas c'est pour
ça que je peux poser la question parce
que 5 ça ouvre quand même les cases ça
enferme un petit peu mon foot 15 noire
et je suis pas sûr de vraiment vraiment
vouloir faire ça par exemple souvent là
un plan excuse-moi un plan peut-être que
c'est des c'est débile mais une idée vu
que la position elle est un peu fermée
au centre une idée qui sera je pense
très très dur à faire mais d'essayer de
coulisser en fait tu vois le petit fou
ici pour placer éventuellement le four à
C4 échanger les fous et mettre un carré
là pour être une superbe idée bon
malheureusement en pratique ce sera plus
dur que ça sera plus dur hein parce que
sur un cahier 5 et après aussi le pion
des trois oui mais dans l'idée en fait
une fois que tu joues 5 moi tu lâches
des cases blanches en fait aussi moi je
voyais l'autre diagonale
en plus on est maître de ce coup là
l'autre ne peut pas jouer E5 parce que
ce serait très affaiblissant pour pour
les blancs donc on peut attendre et
jouer des coups de le coup de fouet 6
pour jouer E5 à n'importe quel moment
après mais pas se dévoiler tout de suite
et laisser le pouce circuler c'est ça
mais je sais que guéri il est c'est
master troll à
200% donc du coup son côté condescendant
je pense que c'est beaucoup trop là
après je le connais pas perso hein je
vais pas vous dire
je sais qui il adore se friter mais en
trollant en fait sur les réseaux sociaux
sur Twitter etc c'est un petit peu le
roi du troll mais c'est jamais vraiment
méchant quoi
c'est bonne guerre quoi
il fait beaucoup de nuls c'est vrai mais
il a un style quand même ou ici il
essaie de jeu pour gagner quoi il fait
des choses quoi c'est pas mec qui fait
nul c'est pas grave voilà
c'était souvent les nuls les nuls qui
[Musique]
dirige j'ai l'impression qu'il essaie un
peu plus de jouer mais bon
ça dépend parce qu'on a des exemples et
des contre-exemples par exemple quand on
a vu au championnat du monde de Blitz où
il a fait nul sans jeu contre Naka alors
que il avait les blancs etc bon tu vois
donc il y a toujours des exemples et
contre exemple
pour agiri mais de manière générale
c'est même si il fait des nuls et ben il
joue quand même c'est pas des des nuls
vraiment
rapide ou un pet quoi
et apparemment il a quand même des
supporters
Barbot qui est complètement fou amoureux
de dirige je pense très bien avec
Christy et
ouais c'est un des plus gros fans
j'aurais dû le plus gros mais maintenant
que on voit que si dans le chat
peut-être qu'au final on a trouvé
quelqu'un qui veut rivaliser avec avec
barbix pour son amour aguerri
mais c'est vrai que ce qui fait dans les
ouvertures même en tant que je
positionner c'est quand même assez
intéressant
voilà donc on est OK pour ça et on nous
a dit que il y avait digne qui
apparemment avait un bon avantage contre
alors un légère avantage pardon contre
bouquet
c'est pas ce qui nous apparaît de ça
alors cavalier C5 pour défendre le pion
des 4 il attaque le pion A4 alors que
tout à l'heure on vous a dit que les
pions du centre c'était plus important
mais il existe
pas facile parce que dans tout à l'heure
l'argument qu'on vous a donné était tout
à fait vrai dans une certaine position
et là il y a son contre-exemple costaud
va nous expliquer tout simplement ben
tout simplement en fait là j'ai une
majorité de contraintes avec quelqu'un
que c'est quand même assez avancé du
coup si je mange à 4 ça peut être
intéressant pour vite pousser me créer
un peu passé d'autant plus que j'ai la
paire de fou dans la paire de fou les
pions passés sont vraiment forts autre
chose qu'après la prise du pur des
quatre et ben le pion des trois reste
malgré tout
un pion arrière vous voyez ce qui aime
du mal à bouger ce pion des trois et
c'est un petit cible sur le long terme
tout à fait et nul de Carlson
apparemment sauf
ah ouais c'est ce que je vois dans les
petits réseaux
ok alors on va voir en fait je moi
souvent je rate des coups
alors est-ce qu'on
des 15 minutes tu ouvras ils nous ont
mis le résultat avant que ça soit signé
je vais vous enlever très très vite
parce que moi quand je le vois encore la
caméra voilà
[Rires]
on est désolé
[Musique]
et moi je plonge tu sais et terrible
terrible
la prochaine fois
je serai bon écoute on va voir ce qui
s'est passé
ok moi j'ai deux et ton D7 et au final
ben il a du mal à un petit peu à avancer
il est perdu
encore une fois le coup tour à deux déjà
pose problème ce pion B en fait tu peux
pas être à la fois actif et à la fois
des fonds
peut-être un moment mais bon on a encore
peut-être que nous on a parce
qu'apparemment Mathieu il avait l'air de
dire que ça allait
mais visuellement moi ça m'a l'air fort
mais peut-être que tout va vite du coup
poser problème que du coup moi j'ai pas
le temps en fait tu vois de jouer B4 à
cause de du tournoi à chaque fois donc
au final peut-être que c'était juste une
fausse alerte quoi OK
ok je fais ça
ok je pense que ça va avec tout à 5 on a
réglé comme ça peut-être
OK et maintenant je joue
ce que j'ai du mal à percuter sauf si tu
veux c'est pourquoi enfin ce qu'il a
joué c'est très bien donc là je joue B4
mais ça a l'air d'être une version
améliorée de la partie
d'ailleurs cette dame c'est ça que je te
pique ton coup tu sais et j'essaie
d'argumenter derrière parce que moi
très convaincu parce que tu avais dit
5 c'est le coup qui qui m'avait l'air
d'être clairement le numéro
c'était mon coup initialement et quand
avant qu'il le joue tu as proposé dams 5
je me suis dit c'est meilleur parce que
tu contrastes
[Musique]
je contrôle à 5 du coup pour éviter
contre
ouais je me doutais enfin c'était une
des trucs mais pour l'instant tu avais
le mal de couloir
il fait la tronche ah ouais bon je peux
encore jouer HK de toute façon ouais
c'est une position que tu peux un peu
poussé
de ce que
après je sais pas enfin ah oui le gars
c'était dame de 6 d'ailleurs sur
tourbéen avec sans doute la 8e rangée
peut-être il commence à peut-être du
coup je sais pas trop comment
placée d'ailleurs le contre jeu d'un
rognon dans la partie ça a été la
cinquième rangée
on aurait pu vraiment travailler
beaucoup des Noirs ce serait pas que je
dame bit
pour enlever le vis-à-vis et partir en
fait là où là quoi c'est sympa mais je
suis toujours pas extrêmement fan dans
le sens moi non plus écoute il y aura
toujours dame après après tu vas
peut-être me contrer sur la première
donc c'est bien dans B8 quand même c'est
une belle idée si ça marche parce que il
faut faire gaffe quand même parce que
c'est quand même une menace
puis la 8e rangée aussi il faut faire
gaffe quand tu fais d'un B8 mais
heureusement tu as le Pione 5 pour me
après
comme B5 je peux justement 5 et passer
par là
il est pas content je pense qu'il va
faire nul
je pense qu'il va reposer nul là
il a pas l'air content
un petit pressing je pense après c'est
des positions qu'il a l'habitude de
pousser ce qu'on peut constater c'est
quand même la très bonne gestion de rien
qui a réussi au niveau en terme de de
temps à poser des problèmes un petit peu
petit pressing
en tout cas cette position était
vraiment intéressante voir ce qui s'est
passé dans la partie
en fait c'est globalement la même chose
mais regarde on vient de regarder
quasiment la position similaire mais il
a donné E5 en fait par rapport à ce
qu'on regardait et la dame aurait dû
être normalement malmenée en plus
après on a peut-être une meilleure
défense noire mais sur dame C5 quand on
a réussi à poser des problèmes donc il a
fait dans mes fuites j'ai vu la caméra
c'est la partie
donc il veut bien sûr manger et venir
sur 15 blanche
et tour des 8 on ignore
menace maths
et donc là du coup
attention
le roi qui va sortir par ici
avec l'option à 5 protégé par la dame B5
heureusement
il y a quand même deux pions de plus
mais il y a dans mes chèques d'un point
prise
de consolidation c'est quoi comment on
fait pour
qu'est-ce que je peux manger vite
bon j'aurai le tour au dos de contre
tous ce que je pensais je sais pas ce
que ça vaut un truc comme ça
il y aura dame
[Musique]
peut-être chaque échec
S
[Musique]
voilà
quelque chose dans ce goût là
c'est du coup des échecs blancs ça va
faire nul je pense
ça ça va faire nul a priori par
répétition parce que vous voyez que les
Noirs ne pourront pas mettre le roi en
E5 c'est nul
c'est quoi je veux dire un truc à ce
niveau là il faut pas monter le roi
jusqu'au bout parce que sinon on va
c'est peut-être ça que donc
et les gens vont serrer la main
on va G6
et Magnus qui fait nul avec les blancs
du coup
dans cette partie
donc c'est pas un super état pour lui
avec les Blancs qui voulaient mettre un
peu la pression
mais
ok bon quand même donc
et là ce qui est fou c'est quand vous
ennuie Carson qui va perdre peut-être
un point et demi voire deux points et
l'eau et puis je jouais pas le pigeon du
coin à rognan une des légendes des
échecs mondiaux
belle partie d'art rognon après
il y a eu un moment critique il a pas
l'air très content Magnus de lui non
je ne pense pas hyper convaincu si tu
veux de ce qu'a jouer à rognan mais il a
rien obtenu il le sait donc ça l'a
énerve un petit peu
beaucoup de respect pour
[Musique]
des deux joueurs pour l'un et l'autre
bah c'est pas le mec qu'on carotte
facilement
c'est pas c'est pas en tentant un petit
piège qu'on voit le battre à rognan
enfin très très grosse partie même pour
Carlson il doit s'employer pour battre
un arrogant voilà voilà crossy
intéressante dessus qu'on peut aller
voir sur
ah oui alors je vais voir si parce que
au niveau des caméras
je crois que j'ai toujours pas de cam
sur Google
[Musique]
je crois que tu vas pouvoir tu vas
pouvoir noter cette partie stouf
dans tes petites à conserver parce qu'en
fait ils ont joué un peu ce qu'on avait
dit tu vois il y a eu regarde
et
j'ai 5 non mais j'ai 5 c'est juste
énorme on casse en fait il y a quand
même un principe qui existe depuis les
premiers champions du monde des chats
comme Stanis c'est on casse les cases
fortes des cavaliers les avant-postes
mais mais là c'est très très fort G5
elle cavalier va où n'a pas de case
cavalier dominée
c'est assez énorme parce que c'est quand
même conceptuel et considérant qu'on a
le fou de case noire c'est pas trop
grave ce que l'on a affaibli
c'est-à-dire les cases F6 et G7
monstrueuse tout enfin quand même c'est
clair
c'est bon
tu peux te permettre en fait de faire ça
parce qu'au final le tout et j'ai 5 au
final tu vois que c'est toi qui est mal
placé qui est un peu aux fraises de fou
en Descartes il faut que toute la
position il est vraiment trop fort il
bloque les deux colonnes ouvertes ici il
contrôle les cases noires et bien sûr
est impossible de se fout il est
vraiment très très fort en des quatre et
tu vois
clairement que les pièces blanches sont
désormais
et le foot case noir c'est le monstre de
l'échiquier incroyable la domination du
foot 15 Noah G4 F5 ou non mais c'est
rigolo cette séquence F5 aussi alors
pourquoi G4 j'imagine que les Noirs
menacés peut-être un coup du style
je crois que c'est peut-être pour quatre
souffle pour améliorer le flou blanc et
tenir le cavalier à chaque avec un pion
pour libérer notre foi F3 de sa
contrainte de protection peut-être que
j'ai quatre il faut 4 comme tu le dis
contre bien les cases blanches de chez
bloque un peu à ton tour un carré G3
sur le futur
la séquence
G4 F5
à la maison
parce que il ouvre son roi bon lui c'est
ce qu'il fait mais
il a intérêt en tout cas il a intérêt à
savoir ce qu'il fait parce que là son
roi est complètement à poil tout d'un
coup et la position allait elle est elle
est très très difficile à
jouer à comprendre parce que tu vois il
y avait déjà un pion de plus tout à
l'heure bon là il a rendu il jouait F5
qui est un prisme
prend il a tout fuite ça c'est assez je
pense en tout cas que ça fait mal tout
refuite
et ce qui est important je trouvais
c'est que après un coup comme échec par
exemple voilà et ben comme le foot tous
en case noir ben il y a rien à faire
pour l'instant
et si je recule madame et ben je reste
de me prendre à retour là et encore
échec en dessin
très très difficile à gérer avec le roi
H8 peinard
est-ce que sur dame
avec une idée par exemple
cette double menace ton tour
c'est un coup un peu préparatoire tu
vois qui a l'air très malin et bon en
prise mais après dans le cadre mais bon
tant que tu as quand même deux en l'air
aussi derrière
quand même
fuite c'était plus parlant avec la
menace sur F2 je trouvais que ça mettait
plus de pression que vous c'est 8 ça a
l'air intéressant si vous c'est 8 mais
ouais donc dans ça a l'air dur à faire
et j'ai en France la totale souffre avec
G4 je pense je pense que c'est ça qui
veut lui envoyer dans la tronche
peut-être G4 mais c'est marrant un tout
beau
faire dame G5 sont ouvertes ouais faut
prendre peut-être droit je suis aussi ça
peut être la mort lente non mais l'idée
en fait sur certains c'est une défon ton
fou là tu es cloué du coup j'ai du tout
au dos
il est en train de faire une partie
c'est monstrueux donc du coup le
pronostic tu comprends maintenant il
voulait jouer pour gagner
il voulait bien sûr en fait
objectivement non mais je comprends tout
à fait je pense que c'est prendre des 5
leur dit je regarderai la position
l'ordi doit dire c'est prendre des cinq
je pense mais prends des 5 c'est
beaucoup plus déséquilibré après j'ai
pas été subjugué par cavalier e1d3 de
goutage surtout vu la suite de la partie
après bouquet j'aurais joué cavalier 1
cavalier 3 contre des joueurs comme nous
ça aurait été plus tranquille pour lui
je pense il aurait passé une meilleure
après la digue Irène il joue aux échecs
à la fois hyper propre vous avez vu la
technique pour la valorisation du
foodcas noir et après des échecs de
folie avec une créativité incroyable et
c'est pour ça qu'il arrive à abattre
enfin à battre à mettre une pression
énorme sur un des meilleurs jeunes au
monde un des plus grands espoirs des
échecs mondiaux quoi
est-ce que vous voulez aller voir un
petit peu la partie de Prague
Prague qui était mon poulain l'année
dernière
qui joue contre iRig Asie toujours son
prénom de moi mais il met la pression
avec des pièces tu vois
beaucoup plus agréable pour les blancs
depuis le début
de mois sauf pour être tout à fait franc
je l'ai occulté aussi parce qu'on a un
super jeu de pièces et qu'on fait suer
l'adversaire depuis tout à l'heure en
même temps parce que le cavalier des 8
c'est la mocheté un carnet
non c'est clair et donc
ericasi qui a joué tout tempo au début
il avait 1h36 au bout de vingtaine de
coups et il avait l'air d'avoir balancé
la prépa et au final maintenant bah
écoute les Blancs ont une position plus
agréable avec un roi qui est plus en
sécurité les pièces plus active c'est un
thème C8 qui peut arriver avec du Tour
Eiffel et du tour d'essai et aussi un
problème sur le cavalier
[Musique]
d'ailleurs du reste cette partie elle
est aussi assez incroyable parce que ça
vient de prise H4 me semble-t-il cette
position
et du coup on voit que le joueur blanc
donc pragnananda a donné à égaliser un
pion pour décompensions long terme sous
fin c'était pas facile à percevoir
c'était assez incroyable en fait bon
c'est préparé je pense acheter
que le pion il est pas prenable etc il
connaît un peu les conséquences il y ait
qu'il a pris et tempo
bon tu vois
donc les deux joueurs ça va un petit peu
au milieu les pieds mais cette pollution
pour moi elle est beaucoup plus
difficile à jouer en pratique pour les
Noirs parce qu'en fait les noirs sont à
chaque fois un fil quoi tu vois je suis
à un coup de perdre à chaque fois
tellement il y a des problèmes dans la
position tu vois le roi sur case noire
le cavalier qui joue pas les pièces qui
sont bien remplacées
bon je peux tout manger des trucs
ça marche pas parce que j'avais pas vu
chien et je l'avais pas vu qu'on
inspiration je suis deg je l'avais pas
vu moi ton dessin
rapide parce que je joue au hasard et
c'est après avoir vu que je calcule les
problèmes et les conséquences
extrêmement mal
dit merde non ça va
c'est ce que je fais à chaque fois dans
les parties strictement comme ça que je
que je calcule
donc mais c'est vrai que ton dessin
et bien sûr ici
il attend il se dit c'est bon viens me
chercher
en fait Prague il passe pas
alors que je préférais vraiment comme
toi les blancs c'est un aspect visuel
aussi vous le comprenez bien je pense en
fait c'est pas facile de faire la
différence vraiment pas facile comment
je vais faire
je sais pas stouf maintenant quand j'ai
l'impression aussi une problématique que
l'on a vu que tout vient de me faire
comprendre que dame C8 n'était pas une
menace à cause du brillant tour des cinq
défensif bah je sais plus quoi jouer ce
que je sais pas comment avancer ma tour
des six elle est forte mais elle est
bloquée le cavalier E4 il est fort mais
il tient la tour des 6 donc il peut pas
se barrer et Madame C4 elle est obligée
de rester contre les D5 donc en fait je
crois qu'on peut plus vraiment bouger
avec les Blancs c'est assez hallucinant
mais notre discours a radicalement
changé et Regal ici il a bien compris je
pense que ça faisait un moment que
Prague était en train plutôt de pousser
mais il s'est fait avoir par une défense
précise Dario merguezi et maintenant ça
va être ça va être compliqué
je voulais déjà dit mais maintenant
c'est sauf qu'il m'avait parlé de ça
goût cash rejoint Mulhouse donc au
prochain au prochain Top ce qui fait qui
a regaizi et et
Google et il n'y a le Sarine seront
partenaire de deux clubs voilà il ne
reste plus qu'à récupérer du coup son
adversaire du jour le petit Prague voilà
pour avoir la team complète de tous les
meilleurs indiens
au niveau du club de Mulhouse ouais
c'est vraiment des joueurs qui qui joue
pour la win est vraiment les joueurs qui
et qui veulent gagner et donc grâce à
cela d'ailleurs qu'on fait des bons
résultats en top sauf c'est pas grâce
aux performances de terriers Rif etc tu
vois ça c'est le niveau Barbot l'oiseau
quoi tu vois c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
voilà c'est
à toute une frange de joueurs tu vois
rive barbeaux l'oiseau sérieux ça c'est
c'est quand même
Rif au moins la différence je parle de
Jean-Noël bien sûr mon capitaine
d'équipe il est grand maître et ça on
peut pas lui enlever
alors que on attend un petit peu les
autres à ce niveau-là
normalement encore en forme pour aller
chercher le titre c'est jeunot
du coup alors qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
aller voir maintenant qu'on a compris je
crois que ben c'est dur pragnat il
réfléchit parce que il sait pas quoi
jouer non plus ça doit être un petit peu
difficile quand même
c'est trop il y a encore tour de 5 tout
le temps
malheureusement je vais te décevoir mais
je joue pas assez ça c'est une éducable
il faut jouer allez 5 6 7 tours par an
minimum comme j'en ai en fait un pour
l'instant c'est pas c'est pas comme ça
que je vais récupérer de la pratique
après tu me diras il faut faire des des
bons tournois qu'on en joue mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut jouer plus hein plus tu
pratiques mieux c'est
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien mais
c'est trop trop dur de te concilier
comme on le disait que je trouve tout à
l'heure on fait des streams on fait des
vidéos on fait des cours et du coup bah
ça le baisse pas de place à d'autres
choses à tout
c'est compliqué et plus la vie perso
aussi qui est bien donc sauf nous
racontait qu'il avait déménagé
moi j'ai une petite fille aussi etc bon
bref je vais pas raconté ma vie mais bon
on a on est tous bien occupé voilà par
les différentes contraintes de vie on
grandit ou on vieillit c'est selon mais
en tout cas on peut pas on peut pas tout
faire et les échecs ça prend énormément
de temps vous le voyez le tata style là
que font les joueurs qui sont
professionnels c'est 15 jours un tournoi
normal c'est plutôt une semaine mais une
semaine à chaque fois le top le Top 16
des 15 jours aussi non allez c'est 12
jours et c'est énorme il faut partir la
veille revenir le lendemain bon bref
vous en êtes pour 14 jours c'est deux
semaines aussi vous voyez c'est
compliqué quoi très compliqué du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on va aller voir la est-ce
qu'on irait pas voir michera d'ailleurs
on peut aller voir
c'est c'est
le petit grand maître qui qui a tout
juste 13 ans
et qui a des blancs et qui joue contre
Helline Robert qui vient de passer à
miuelle et aussi elle est jeune c'est
une jeune qui a à peu près 16 ans je
dirais ouais
14 ans des moins de 14 j'ai déjà joué
contre son papa deux fois parce que en
fait son papa l'amenait partout à chaque
tournoi que j'ai pu faire sauf j'en fais
pas beaucoup son papa l'amenait et c'est
un joueur à 2100 2200 son papa fois
qu'il est maître Fides et
du coup il a amené partout pour que ça
ça jeune fille progresse et a fait des
progrès de dingue je l'ai connu elle
était 2000 2100 et maintenant elle est
bon elle avait pas ça veut dire qu'elle
a passé les 2004 donc elle est ultra
forte
au Festival des Jeux à Cannes l'année
dernière et
et non elle est très très très forte
elle joue beaucoup c'est la clé
rapidement
[Musique]
ok
du coup là ça s'est pas très bien passé
pour pour vous dire puisque on a donné
notre case noire et les cases noires ce
sont ouvertes donc du coup il y a la
grande grande diago le pion c'est 5 fixé
sur noir et on va avoir bientôt ce qu'on
appelle les pions pendant les pions
pendant ça a les deux pions qui vont
rester au milieu regardez il a préparé
tout cela et un moment il va faire pion
pendant
voilà puis on prend et voilà il est
attaque les pions pendant les 15 noirs
sont ouvertes et là on va gêner le
défenseur des pions pendant les pions
pendant c'est les deux copains qui sont
au milieu mais qui sont pas soutenus par
des pions et là c'est le drame vous
voyez le fougère de michera on s'attaque
à la structure il a le temps il améliore
ses pièces les pièces noires sont dégueu
et un moment il va simplement
bouffer le pion C5 on a vu sur l'image
finale que ça commençait à être la cata
faut juste regarder D4
qui bon serait le bar route d'honneur
sans doute pour voilà il faut F3 dame
prend F3 que nous montre stouf bien sûr
parce que sinon on a des problèmes
donc tout reprend ses 5 D4 qu'est-ce que
je vais jouer pour pour défendre je peux
même peut-être jouer le tout petit F3
voilà peut-être F3 tranquillement et si
ça passe pas c'est hyper chaud parce que
maintenant j'ai des tours prend des
quatre j'ai dames G3 aussi mais ouais
cavalier kart c'est bizarre comme
aliment de pièces donc F3 F5 peut-être
j'ai cédé un truc quoi bon F5 aurait
simplement foi CH5 en plus enfin bon
c'est sûr que ça va pas marcher tout
reprend des quatre par la suite
j'ai l'impression qu'on va se faire
raser avec les Noirs 15 minutes contre 7
minutes
la jeune Éline
ça peut être bon tracks les pions
pendant mais il faut éviter d'avoir
échangé une pièce mineure là c'était le
cas donc il faut essayer de garder un
maximum de pièces parce que les pions
pendant ça t'amène tout le centre
donc quand tu as tout le centre faut un
maximum de pièces sur l'échiquier de ton
côté un maximum de pièces comprimées
chez l'adversaire et tu vas avoir des
compensations dynamiques parce que c'est
des faiblesses sur le long terme là
finalement il n'y a pas eu du tout de
compensation avec les Noirs comme je
l'ai dit les pièces de des lignes Robert
c'était coincées donc là bah tu te fais
tu te fais bien enfoncer on rappelons
câline et joue très très bien mais elle
a 23 60 elle est jeune
elle va apprendre à la dure dans son nom
je peux vous le dire alors j'aimerais
bien pour elle qu'elle fasse un tournoi
exceptionnel
mais ça va être facile elle va affronter
pas mal de données
mettre en avant les jeunes joueurs les
jeunes talents et du coup elle c'est un
jeune talent mais c'est la moins forte
clairement du groupe et à part elle les
joueurs ont quasiment tous 2600 euros ou
quasiment et du coup c'est quand même un
tournoi et puis en plus c'est 2006 mais
c'est souvent des jeunes tu vois déjà où
les stars
c'est vraiment très très ouais l'horreur
c'est des joueurs soit 2006-2007 très
expérimenté soit des jeunes pépites
comme nous la disent tous donc
ça va être très très chaud la fin du
monde non
elle s'appelle la jeune casaque là non
en 2014
[Musique]
moins de 14 ans comme je l'ai dit mais
je savais pas que c'était en blitz
pour moi c'était
championne du monde tout court en moins
de 14 en moins de 14 ans 2021 donc ça ça
serait bon je vais
voilà médaille d'argent du premier
échiquier à l'olympiade
cette année et championne du monde chez
les filles des moins de 14 ans donc vu
qu'elle a vu que c'était il y a 2 ans ça
collerait avec ce que nous dit Quentin
souffre mais je sais pas si c'était en
blitz ou non
c'est toi qui vérifie on te fait
totalement confiance
et du coup en tout cas bon bah là elle
est en train de
souffrir
personnellement
je pensais même à jouer au 4 tu vois
tellement je te disais que
tu es intéressant
[Musique]
peut-être que c'est un peu tiré par les
cheveux cette histoire moi pourquoi pas
j'y avais pas pensé mais j'ai
l'impression que en fait j'ai
l'impression on a une multitude de coups
si tu veux si tu fais que
[Musique]
si ça marche c'est que pour des 5 c'est
que je peux manger des cadres
8 mais bon ok je crois que c'est tout
est bon ouais non ça a l'air ça mais ok
bon c'était une proposition mais est-ce
qu'on irait pas avoir la partie ici de
rapport parce que l'échec s'est vidé
et
il reste plus beaucoup de pièces alors
attends on en était on avait dit qu'il
allait souffrir un groupe
tout à fait et on avait dit que on sait
pas quoi faire waouh intéressant tour
des cinq déjà la conception il a vu que
ça tourbait 5 n'arrivait plus à attaquer
le roi depuis cavalier B8 et vient les
changer c'est hyper mal la tour elle va
être très mal placée elle aura plus rien
à faire donc ici bah tant qu'à faire je
vais changer ce qui est malin mais nous
on n'a pas envie de le faire parce qu'on
a quand même une tour ici et on aurait
aimé plus tard attaquer ouvrir la
pollution donc il a compris que ça
n'allait plus
comprendre
bien dit donc c'est même si tu comprends
et que tu vois le fait de le faire c'est
encore autre chose j'ai envie de dire je
pense que je n'aurais pas fait moi
j'aurais essayé malgré tout de trouver
un truc même si je sais que tu vois
c'est un peu dur des fois il y a des
concepts comme ça
donc maintenant le pion de d'Arnaud
mairesse n'est plus en prise parce que
le casse des 5 n'est plus n'est plus
autorisé
et j'avais plus le j'avais pas vu la
référence de crusty les Noirs manquent
de perspective je pense qu'il parlait de
la position de la jeune Éline tout à
l'heure pas de coupe piquant pas de coup
de pression pas de coup de menaçant et
là c'est une dédicace et oui et c'est
tout à fait ça et du coup c'était très
très très très
compliqué pour cette jeune ça c'est ça
c'est un coup bizarre
oui mais parce qu'il a eu peur de F4
stouf je pense parce que elle est 17 il
y a plus de Fougères
c'est qu'il y a plus fougère enfilade ou
clouage quoi absolu mais du coup du coup
très très dur
très très dur si je mange là
me fait que de bugger chez moi
dès que je joue un coup il me refuse je
n'y suis pour rien sachez-le
ce que je voulais dire c'est que si
prenait le 5 je pensais qu'il y avait
tout
et clouage et surtout qui défend ben je
pense à un fou français
[Musique]
6 en fait t'as l'impression que c'est
pas possible parce que tu es cloué mais
attention qu'en fait quand je fais
qu'elle progressiste je suis cloué mais
je découvre moi aussi une une pièce mais
en fait quand je prends la dame tu
manges madame mais à la fin je prends la
bien juste tout donc bon c'est une
tactique qui qui peut marcher marche pas
enfin tu vois tu sais pas trop il faut
vraiment aller jusqu'au bout
mais clairement
par contre
ici mais je prends ces 6 justement
ouais c'est peut-être alors faut
vérifier oui oui ça a l'air de marcher
parce que du coup ouais
il aurait le monopole de gaz blanche
oui ça perce donc comme ça comme ça et
même du H4 plus tard pour ouvrir aussi
la colonage qui est intéressant comme
concept de la part de ce rapport H3 d'un
match de G4
pas évident les caves à prendre 5 avec
les jouets donc il est évidente
tu peux ouvrir la position c'est logique
de pas faire avec quelqu'un c'est
logique d'essayer de manger en le 5 mais
après faut faire attention parce que les
Blancs la part de fou aussi donc
l'ouverture de la position
pourraient éventuellement se retourner
contre lui quoi tu vois tout à fait donc
donc je pense qu'il a raison d'ouvrir la
pollution mais il faut faire attention
prise donc là bien sûr attention car si
prendre la dame il peut y avoir des fois
des trucs avec fougères madame pour
l'instant j'ai mon cavalier donc ça
marche pas mais c'est le thème 3 in
extremis il faut garder ça en thème en
tête pardon donc avaler prend F3 a été
joué
donc on est obligé de manger pour
récupérer de la pâte arrière et après ça
j'avais déjà que les Noirs
[Musique]
quasiment un pion plus non merci on
gagne ce pion là c'est terminé
d'ailleurs en plus c'est fini parce que
tu défends tes pions enfin tu as pas ici
ça va faire beaucoup c'est pas facile
parce que j'ai pas de avec mon fou je
peux pas t'empêcher toujours c'est 5 tu
coupes donc je pense qu'il faut très
très vite essayer de faire un truc il
s'est passé quoi il faut B2 ok sur ce
qui se passait quoi au juste cinq
peut-être une tentative de ces trois
mais bon
structure pour ouvrir ce fou et essayer
d'empêcher au final le petit roi c'est 7
ou avec
il y a aussi du Fou G7
rapporte pour le défendre
après ça commence à se décanter hein
de Vincent Kemer et de Max Zurich
en fait il a réussi à manger deux pièces
pour la tour on s'est arrêté à tour à 5
dans la partie et on avait parlé cette
position on avait dit qu'ici les Noirs
avaient l'air d'être mieux franchement
j'ai des meilleures pièces et le centre
qu'on a dit structure plus yes s'active
ah pour essayer de changer la structure
et de s'activer c'est ça du coup B4 a
été joué qui logique qui permet de de
se libérer de cette faiblesse anglaise
d'ouvrir la position essayer de trouver
des casques pour ces pièces donc c'est
un coup tout à fait logique d'ailleurs
c'était le meilleur coup de la
production pour le moment et
[Musique]
du coup les noirs
dame D1 tout reprendre a
bah oui tu reprends des trois kss5 voilà
c'est 5 et et
tu reprends à 3
[Musique]